Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und hier geht's munter weiter in unserer Gesprächsreihe rund um die Raumfahrt. Und für die heutige 28. Ausgabe hat es mich nach Darmstadt verschlagen, ein weiteres Mal hier am Standort des ESOC. Und ja, das Thema dreht sich heute ganz um die Seite der Raumfahrt, die sich am Boden abspielt, denn es reicht ja nicht alleine nur Raumfahrzeuge in die weiten Welten zu schicken. Man muss auch den Kontakt zur Erde immer halten und Kontrolle behalten über das, was da oben fliegt. Und dazu ist ein komplexes Netzwerk erforderlich von Bodenstationen und anderen Infrastruktureinheiten. Und um darüber Auskunft zu geben, begrüße ich für die heutige Ausgabe als Gesprächspartner Thomas Beck. Ja, ich habe es schon gesagt, wir sind am ESOC und das ist auch dein Arbeitsplatz hier. Genau genommen bist du aber Teil einer Untergruppe, der ESA genannt, ESTRACK, E-S-T-R-A-C-K. Bevor wir darauf kommen, was beim ESTRACK genau getan wird und was die ganze Infrastruktur der Bodenstation eigentlich konkret ausmacht, würde mich wie immer erstmal interessieren, wieso eigentlich dein persönlicher Weg gewesen ist hier in die Raumfahrt und vor allem dann eben auch, was es genau ist, was du hier eigentlich machst.
Vielleicht ganz kurz. Also ESTRACK ist die Bezeichnung des Bodenstations-Netzwerkes. Es ist keine eigene Organisation in der ESA. Es ist nur diese sozusagen Installationsanlagen-Bezeichnung. Mein Weg in die ESA hat mich vor vielen Jahren, mehr als 20 Jahre, nach Darmstadt geführt. Damals war ich Absolvent eines für damalige Verhältnisse recht aufregenden europäischen Studiengangs. Das war ein Studiengang zwischen der Universität Karlsruhe, einer Ingenieurschule in Paris, und der Universität von Essex in England. Eines der ersten Tripartite-Programme in den 80er Jahren.
Was für ein Programm?
Ein Tripartite, ein Drei-Parteien-Programm, also ein integriertes europäisches Auslandsstudium. Und die Absolventen, meine Kollegen von damals und ich, sind noch einige in der ESA gelandet, weil die ESA für so eine Ausbildung fast der perfekte Arbeitgeber ist. Man kann hier technisch arbeiten, in einem globalen, weltweiten Kontext. Man trifft viele Kollegen aus europäischen, aber auch nicht europäischen Ländern. Deswegen kam ich damals als junger Ingenieur begeistert zur ESA. Ich habe damals teilgenommen an einem Trainee-Programm, das damals frisch aufgelegt war, eben für Absolventen. Das Programm ist immer noch in Existenz. Also wenn einige Zuhörer Interesse hätten. Ich kann das Trainee-Programm nur wärmstens empfehlen. Nach diesem Einstieg in damals eine Entwicklungsabteilung für Bodenstationselemente, haben wir dann über die Jahre verschiedene Positionen inne gehabt. Erst im Bereich Entwicklung, dann in der Projektierung, im Projektmanagement. Jetzt bin ich in einem Bereich tätig, in dem wir den Betrieb des ESTRACK-Netzwerkes organisieren und durchführen.
Was war denn der ursprüngliche Sinn und Zweck dieses Programms, dieses Dreifachstudiums, drei Teile Studiums?
Das eine war das Studium. Das war ein Studium der Fachrichtung Nachrichtentechnik, Telekommunikation im heutigen Begriff. Das war ein Grundstudium in Deutschland. In dem Fall waren es drei Jahre in der Uni Karlsruhe, ein Jahr in Paris an der Ecole Supérieure dort und ein Jahr an der Uni in Essex mit einem ganz normalen Abschluss, der zwischen diesen drei Hochschulen ausgetauscht werden konnte. Das ist ein ganz normales Studium, kein Raumfahrtbezug direkt. Das Trainee-Programm bei der ESA war ein damals frisch aufgelegtes Programm für Absolventen, um junge Leute für das Raumfahrtthema zu begeistern und die in die ESA reinzubringen. Eine erste Erfahrung, die über dieses Programm finanziert worden ist.
Aber das wendet sich jetzt nicht nur an Nachrichtentechniker, sondern das ist so ein generelles Trainee-Programm für Ingenieure.
Das Trainee-Programm damals und heute rechtlich in alle Disziplinen, die in der ESA gesucht werden. Das sind Naturwissenschaftler, Techniker primär, aber auch Juristen und Wirtschaftler. Aber es ist nicht ein fachthemabezogenes Programm. Es gilt generell für alle Abschlüsse, die in der ESA Verwendung finden können, die hier gebraucht werden. Ich habe also auch schon Biologen gesehen, Raumfahrtmediziner, die meisten Naturwissenschaftler und Techniker.
Und wann kann man sich dafür bewerben, in dem Moment, wo man in einem Studium ist? Oder muss das schon irgendwie an dieses Studium angekoppelt sein?
Also die Bewerbung läuft meines Wissens immer noch heute so, dass man sich im letzten Studienjahr dann bewerben kann, direkt bei der ESA. Ich glaube, zurzeit gibt es zwei Auswahlszyklen pro Jahr. Und diese Bewerbung müssten dann halt auf einen Bedarf treffen. Das heißt, die Manager, auch ich, habe in meinem Bereich eine Stelle definiert für einen Trainee mit einem bestimmten Anforderungsprofil. Wenn dann eben dieser Bewerber und das Profil zusammenpassen, dann kann es zu einer Einstellung kommen. In der Regel sind wir auf ein Jahr befristet. Das ist also ein spezielles Trainee-Programm für einen, manchmal zwei Jahre.
Das ist natürlich der ideale Einstieg eigentlich, oder?
Also für mich war das ein ganz berauschender Einstieg. Für die meisten, die es gemacht haben, auch. Weil man eben als junger Mensch dann direkt in die Raumfahrtagentur einsteigen kann, was eher unüblich ist. Die meisten Leute, die wir jetzt einstellen, sind Leute mit ein paar Jahren Berufserfahrung, die dann eben aus der Industrie meistens in die ESA wechseln. Die Absolventen, die direkt kommen, sind eben in der Minderheit.
Ja, wir haben es ja schon, oder ich habe es schon zumindest angesprochen, ESTRACK Bodenstationen, das soll hier das Thema sein und das ist auch dein Thema. Also was ist konkret deine Aufgabe hier?
Also ESTRACK ist einfach die sozusagen Markenbezeichnung für unser Bodenstationsnetz. ESTRACK steht für ESA Tracking Stations, also ein Netzwerk von Bodenstationen, die weltweit verteilt sind. Wir haben momentan neun Standorte in der Welt, in denen diese Bodenstationen stehen. Eine weitere, eine zehnte ist im Aufbaubegriff in Argentinien. Und diese Anlagen, die dort stehen, die haben einen Hauptzweck. Und der Hauptzweck von ESTRACK ist ganz einfach, die Verbindung herzustellen zwischen den Zatelliten im Weltraum, den diversen Raumfahrzeugen und Sonden und dem Kontrollzentrum hier in Darmstadt. Gewissermaßen die Nachrichtengesellschaft, die die Verbindung schafft zwischen dem Kontrollzentrum hier und den verschiedenen Missionen, die sich im Weltraum unterwegs befinden. Und das wird eben erreicht über diese Bodenstationen mit ihren technischen Eigenschaften, die wir gleich noch beschreiben werden. Und dem dazugehörigen Bodennetz, einfach ein Datennetz, ein IP-basierendes Datennetz, das diese Anlagen verbindet. Wie ein Spinnennetz werden die dann mit Darmstadt verbunden, um eben dann diese Verbindung zwischen dem Kontrollzentrum über die Bodenleitung dann über Funkstrecken in den Weltraum zum Raumfahrzeug zu schaffen. Also Hauptzweck ist diese Verbindungsherstellung zum Zwecke von Telemetrieempfang. Also wie geht es zum Raumfahrzeug, was sind die Zustände, welche Nutzlastdaten werden produziert und wie sehen die aus? Also der Fluss der Daten vom Raumfahrzeug zum Boden. Die andere Richtung ist das Telekommando. Die Steuerungsbefehle für die Sonden, für die Satelliten werden über den gleichen Weg natürlich nach oben geschickt in den Weltraum. Ein dritter Zweck von ESTRACK, der ist mir meistens vernachlässigt, ist der über Entfernungsmessungen und Dopplermessungen auch Informationen zu sammeln über die jeweilige Position und Lage des Fahrzeugs, um damit eben Orbits bestimmen zu können. Wir alle wissen heutzutage, wir haben Missionen, die eher nahe fliegen. Das kann man auch mit GPS ganz gut machen, so wie Autos und Flugzeuge in GPS benutzen. Man kann auch ein tief liegender Satelliten-GPS-System haben und damit seine Position recht genau bestimmen. Aber das geht nur in Erdnähe, also unterhalb dieses GPS-Gürtels. Für Erdfernemissionen ist das eben nicht mehr möglich. Und da ist nach wie vor das eben bodenbasierte Ranging- und Dopplermessament die Technik der Wahl.
Wo ist da eigentlich die Grenze, ab wann kann GPS nicht mehr verwendet werden?
Das kann ich jetzt so genau nicht sagen. Wir verwenden das für diese Erdnähenmissionen, also Erdbeobachtung zum Teil. Goji zum Beispiel hat so ein System an Bord. Aber alle wissenschaftlichen Missionen und sicherlich die Interplanetaren haben diese Eigenschaft natürlich nicht.
Ja klar. So, das heißt, das Ganze ist ein riesiges Netzwerk, was eben beileibe nicht nur in Europa ist, das hört man schon, die zehnte Station ist in Argentinien. Man muss natürlich gleich fragen, wo sind die anderen neun? Also wie weit verzweigt ist das? Gibt es hier einen Schwerpunkt irgendwo? Oder geht es darum, dass es möglichst gleichmäßig über den Planeten verteilt ist?
Ein wichtiges Kriterium für ein Bodennetz, Stationsnetz, ist die Lage der einzelnen Stationen. Und zwar ergibt sich das aus den Art der Missionen, die unterstützt werden sollen. Ganz offensichtlich ist der Fall für diese polaren Missionen, in der Regel Erdbeobachtungsmissionen, die ja fast alle polare Umlaufbahnen haben oder geostationär.
Weil die diesen Effekt nutzen, dass sie quasi die Erde unter sich durch rotieren lassen und dadurch eben Stück für Stück jeden Teil der Erde so leicht beobachten können.
Genau, die haben typischerweise relativ tiefe Orbits, 800 Kilometer Höhe. Die haben einen Umlaufdauer von um die 100 Minuten. Das ist dieser typische sonnensynchrone Orbit. Und damit überfliegen die eben einmal pro Orbitrunde den Pol. Und polnahe Stationen sehen deswegen jede Orbitumrundung einmal. Deswegen haben alle Organisationen, die solche Sachen betreiben, auch Anlagen in Polen näher aufgebaut. Wir eben in Nordschweden, in Kiruna. Kiruna ist ja bekannt für zwei Sachen. Als Minenstadt für Stahl und eben auch als große Raumfahrtstadt. Und da hat die ESA eine ESA-eigene Anlage gebaut vor vielen Jahren, die benutzt wird für die Gesamtheit unserer Beobachtungsmission. Also ein polarer Standort ist wichtig für diese Art von Mission.
Kiruna, das in Schweden ist das?
Kiruna ist in Nord-Schweden. Und wie gesagt...
Ist das der einzige Pol-Standort? Also reicht der dann sozusagen schon aus, um alle Pol-Missionen zu beobachten? Oder braucht man da auch mehrere?
Also bei diesen typischen Orbits, die eben angesprochen wurden, umdrehen und jede Revolution zu sehen, ist Kiruna nicht nördlich genug. Von den typischen 10 bis 12 Passagen pro Tag sehen wir nicht alle. Wir sehen 8 bis 10. Das heißt, wenn man wirklich jeden Umlauf sehen möchte, müsste man Stationen haben, die weiter im Norden sind. Da gibt es auch Anlagen von privaten Betreibern auf Spitzbergen. Da gibt es eine Anlage der Norweger. Die haben das sehr groß aufgebaut. Eine semi-kommerzielle Anlage, mit der sie für sehr viele Kunden in der gesamten Welt in Polartracking anbieten. Und auch wir in der ESA nutzen diese Dienste, indem wir die Passagen, die wir nicht von Kiruna sehen können, in der Regel dort als Dienstleistung einkaufen. Wir haben in denen eine Verbindung aufgebaut, eine Bodenverbindung. Und nehmen die Passagen von der Station dort, die wir von unserer nicht sehen können.
Und die restlichen Stationen, wo sind die?
Neben dieser polaren Station für polare Umlaufbahnen hat die ESA auch die herausragendsten Stationen. Die Deep Space Stationen sind in der Regel in der Quaternär. Die Deep Space Stationen für die Erdfernen-Missionen sind eben dazu konzipiert, um die Raumfahrtsonden, die ganz weit rausfließen zu anderen Planeten, zum Mars, zu Venus oder diesen Kometenjäger, den möglichst gut beobachten zu können. Für diese Art von Mission ist eine Quaternär-Stationierung günstig, weil mit dem Quator drehen sich die Stationen sozusagen um die Erdachse. Und eine von den drei, wenn die richtig platziert sind, hat immer Kontakt zu den Sonden, die in der Regel auch in der Planetenebene sich bewegen. Deswegen hat die ESA auch jetzt drei Anlagen gebaut, eine in Australien, in Westaustralien, Nunoche heißt die, eine in Cebreros in Spanien und jetzt eben eine neue Anlage, die aufgebaut wird in Südamerika, an Argentinien bei der Kleinstadt Malarga. Ja, das ist nicht so ganz direkt. Idealerweise wäre auf dieser gleichen Höhe eine Anlage am Equator. Aber da die Ingenieure immer Kompromisse eingehen, ist das auch ein Kompromiss zwischen dem lokalen Klima, den politischen Gegebenheiten, eine sichere Station aufbauen zu können und der technischen Leistungsfähigkeit. Idealerweise wären die drei Stationen direkt am Equator. Aber keine dieser drei, die wir gesehen haben, ist direkt am Equator.
Es ist ja auch so, dass die Planetenebene und die Erdachse auch nicht gerade zueinander sind. Hauptsache, man ist nicht total am Pol, sondern in etwa so, dass einer es halt immer sehen kann. Also drei, damit ein Teil des Universums immer sichtbar ist und dass es auch einen gewissen Handover gibt. Wenn ein beobachtetes Objekt den Sichtbereich einer Station verlässt, dann wird sie von der nächsten Station bereits schon gesehen oder kann gesehen werden.
Bei dreien hat man eine Regel, es ist eine gute Überlappung. Bei zweien wäre es theoretisch denkbar, aber in der Regel ist es nicht praktisch implementierbar.
Da müsste man wirklich nur zwei Stationen haben, die exakt genau auf der anderen Seite liegen. Ist Handover auch ein wirkliches Thema?
Handover wird regelmäßig praktiziert zwischen den Missionen, die die Anlagen überstreichen mit überlappender Sichtbarkeit. Das ist in der Regel der Fall bei diesen Wissenschaftsmissionen, die momentan fliegen, nicht bei den Deep Space Missionen. Wir haben bisher nur zwei Anlagen, die eine geringe Überlappung haben. Da ist es auch ein betriebliches Thema, weil dieses Handover sicher und zuverlässig ausgeführt werden muss.
Was ist jetzt mit den anderen Stationen? Jetzt hatten wir die drei, die am Äquator sind. Das sind die einzigen, die sich jetzt wirklich um Deep Space Missionen kümmern? Oder nur die, die man auf jeden Fall gerne schon mal in dem Bereich hätte, um das überhaupt leisten zu können?
Deep Space Missionen sind die, die weit weg von der Erde fliegen, wie der Name schon sagt. Und deswegen sind die anderen Stationen, die jetzt beschrieben werden, dafür unbedingt geeignet. Weil die anderen Stationen sind in der Regel solche, die in Europa sind. Wir haben in Europa eine Station in Belgien, in Rédu. Wir haben eine in Villafranca. Wir haben noch eine Anlage in Kourou, die ist nun sehr am Äquator. Und diese Anlagen haben einen Antennendurchmesser von nur 15 Meter und sind deswegen für Erdfernemissionen zum Teil nicht benutzbar. Man kann sie einsetzen, solange die Mission noch erdnah fliegt. Sobald sie aber weiter weg sind, ist der Antennengewinn und die Empfangsgüter nicht ausreichend, um diese Erdfernemission zu unterstützen.
Das heißt, die drei Deep Space orientierten Stationen, die haben jetzt auch besonders große Antennen?
Ja, die haben zum einen diese Lagebesonderheit. Die haben natürlich noch ganz wichtig, sehr große Antennen, um eben mit diesen Antennen dann eine sehr starke Bündelungswirkung zu erzeugen für Sende und Empfang. Die haben noch sehr hohe Sendeleistungen, um eben mit diesen sehr weit entfernten Raumfahrtsonden in der Regel zuverlässig Kontakt zu halten.
Und die KORU kümmert sich um alles, was in KORU startet? Oder ist das jetzt nur, weil da sowieso schon ein ESA-Standort ist, dass man da auch noch Antenne hingestellt hat?
Die KORU-Anlage ist eine 15-Meter-Anlage, die jetzt in Äquator näher steht. Aber die ist jetzt nicht unbedingt konzipiert, um den Start von KORU direkt zu unterstützen. Das ist nur eine Lokation, die halt günstig war, weil Guyana ist ein Teil der Europäischen Union, ein sicheres Gelände. Da kann man auf dem amerikanischen Kontinent eben eine Anlage bauen, die von der Infrastruktur des Raumfahrzentrums insgesamt profitiert und dann eben Missionen in diesem Teil der Welt bedienen kann, die dort eine Abdeckung brauchen.
Wäre es nicht naheliegend gewesen, auch so eine Deep Space-Antenne dort noch hinzubauen?
Wie gesagt, wir haben uns anfangs gesprochen, von der Quartur näher her wäre das ein gutes Argument gewesen. Andererseits ist halt das Klima in Kuro extrem ungünstig. Diese großen Antennen, die in der Regel Mixband und Ka-Band arbeiten, sind sehr regenempfindlich, was die Dämpfung anbelangt. In diesen anderen Frequenzbändern, die Kuro ist zum Beispiel eine Anlage, die im S-Band arbeitet, 2 Gigahertz. Die Deep Space-Anlagen arbeiten im X-Band und im Ka-Band. In diesen Frequenzbändern ist Regentämpfung ein großes Problem. Man sucht sich also Gegenden aus, die sehr regenarm sind, trockene Gegenden, um eben diese Regentämpfung zu minimieren. Andererse ist natürlich Interferenz von menschlichen Anlagen. Man möchte weit weg sein von großen Siedlungen, von Industrieanlagen, von Flugplätzen, von Schiffen, weil deren Radaranlagen eben Störungen verursachen, die bei dieser Art von Antennen und von Missionen eben sehr störend sein können.
Okay, das ist natürlich nachvollziehbar. Das heißt, die anderen Stationen sind kleiner und kümmern sich vor allem um die erdnahen Missionen. Das heißt, das sind quasi die Begleiter von allen Formen von Satelliten, vor allem von Erdbeobachtungen, Nachrichtensatelliten, etc.
Also die Beerdbeobachtungsmissionen, die nutzen hauptsächlich, wie gesagt, diese Kiruna-Station, wo sie regelmäßige Überflüge haben, in Kombination mit diesen vorhin beschriebenen externen Anlagen auf Spitzbergen, die wir hinzumieten als unterstützende Station. Die Anlagen, die 5-cm-Anlagen insgesamt unterstützen primär die Wissenschaftsmissionen der ESA, die nicht in den Deep Space-Bereich gehen. Die Missionen wie XMM, wie Integral zum Beispiel, die nicht ganz so hohe Anforderungen an die Empfangsgüte und Antennen-Leichtungsfähigkeit haben.
Was macht denn jetzt so eine Bodenstation? Sind die eigentlich alle gleich, unabhängig von der Antennengröße? Sind die jetzt organisatorisch technisch im Wesentlichen vergleichbar oder unterscheiden die sich dann auch noch nennenswert in irgendwelchen Eigenschaften, diese Bodenstationen?
Also technisch versuchen wir die Anlagen in den Bereichen, wo es möglich ist, zu harmonisieren. Natürlich sind die unterschiedlich eben beschrieben in der Antennengröße. Wir haben da zwei Antennentypen sozusagen, diese ganz großen 35-Meter-Schüsseln für die Deep Space-Anlagen, auch mit den Frequenzbändern entsprechend. Wir haben dann diese 15-Meter-Anlagen, die sind typisch im S-Band-Bereich, abarbeiten die im X-Band. Und natürlich gibt es da innerhalb von diesen Klassen dann eine Gemeinsamkeit. Das heißt, alle 15 Meter Frontends sind gleich, alle Deep Space Frontends sind weitgehend gleich. Und was da hinten dran kommt an Equipment in den einzelnen Anlagen, die ganzen Empfänger, die Sender, die Kodierer, die ganzen Signalverarbeitungsgeräte, das Processing der Daten, die Antennensteuerung, da versuchen wir, alle Anlagen möglichst gleich zu machen, um eben eine Harmonisierung zu erreichen und es ermöglicht, mit geringem Engineering-Aufwand die Anlagen zu konzipieren, zu pflegen und zu betreiben.
Ja, es hat eine Frage der Software, eine Frage der Wartung, der Ersatzteile etc. und auch der Kenntnis, um was nicht so gut funktioniert. Das heißt, die Deep Space Missionen benutzen deutlich höhere Frequenz?
Ja, deutlich höher, ja.
Was ist das so, 8 bis 12 Gigahertz oder so, X-Band? Warum müssen die eine höhere Frequenz benutzen?
Ich gebe eigentlich zwei Hauptargumente für die höheren Frequenzen. Zum einen erreichen sie dann mit höheren Frequenzen eine Kombination von zwei Richtantennen, eine am Boden und eine an Bord, insgesamt einen höheren Durchsatz bei gleicher Sendeleistung. Die Antennen gewinnen an beiden Enden. Antennen gewinnen sozusagen die Bündelungskraft der Antenne, ihre Fähigkeit, den Strahlen zu fokussieren, ist bei hohen Frequenzen höher als bei niedrigen Frequenzen. Das heißt, mit der Frequenz steigt auch die Bündelungskraft dieser beiden Antennen. Deswegen können sie mit gleicher Sendeleistung höhere Datenraten übertragen oder auch höhere Entfernungen überbrücken. Höhere Entfernungen sind für Deep Space Missions natürlich ein Hauptargument.
Aber warum nimmt man dann nicht generell das X-Band auch für die anderen?
Das ist eine historische Entwicklung. S-Band war vor 20 Jahren ein neuer Standard. Er ist eingeführt worden, um eben damals von dem früher existierenden VHF wegzukommen auf S-Band. Das war damals der Standard. Das ist ein Frequenzband, das ist zugewiesen worden für die Space Operations, von der Frequenzband, die dafür geeignet ist. Und es gibt weltweit jede Menge Anlagen, die S-Band Unterstützung leisten können. Das heißt, wenn Sie in eine Mission fliegen, können Sie weltweit von allen Raumfahrtbehörden eine Bodenstation nutzen. Für X-Band ist das nur bedingter Fall. Es gibt nur einige wenige Raumfahrtbehörden, die X-Band TTNC anbieten können. Das ist die ESA, das ist die NASA zum Teil. Aber das ist zum Beispiel kein Frequenzbereich, den kommerzielle Stationsbetreiber oder Satellitenbetreiber installieren für ihre Mission. Das heißt, sie haben da weniger verfügbare Bodensegmentkapazitäten, die sie einfach straight away nutzen können.
Was ist TTNC?
TTNC steht für Telecommand Tracking, Telemetry Tracking und Command. Das sind die beschriebenen Hauptfunktionen dieser Antennen.
Okay, einfach das gängige Kürzel dafür. Okay, verstehe, also X-Band ist dann sozusagen, um Deep Space Missionen zu machen, hat man gesehen, okay, wir brauchen jetzt eigentlich mehr Kapazität, wir brauchen da mehr Power, deswegen ist es besser, in einen höheren Frequenzbereich reinzugehen. Das ist natürlich auch eine Frage der technischen Entwicklung, weil mit so hohen Frequenzen braucht man natürlich auch das entsprechende Equipment, was damit umgehen kann. Das dürfte am Anfang der Raumfahrt noch nicht so ausgeprägt gewesen sein.
Ja, ein weiterer Grund, als würde diese Wanderung uns weiter vom VHF über S-Band hin zu X- und KA-Band, ist aber auch eine intensivere Nutzung dieser S-Band-Bereiche durch kommerzielle Anwendungen. Wir wissen ja, Internet, Mobilfunk ist eine riesen Wave zurzeit. Und viele kommerzielle Anwender drängen in diese Frequenzbänder hinein, wollen sie nutzen. Deswegen werden die Space-Agencies daraus vertrieben, eben in höhere Bänder, die sich auch natürlich betreiben können. Sie haben das technische Know-how und die Mittel dafür. Und die S-Bänder werden jetzt von anderen Anwendern genutzt. Es gibt hier ein sehr interessantes Beispiel, wie wichtig diese Frequenz-Lizenzgeschichten sind für uns. Unsere Bodenstation in Westaustralien, in Perth, ist eine Anlage, die ist konzipiert worden vor über 20 Jahren. Damals war S-Bahn eben der Standard. Aber die Frequenz-Lizenz der Australier für diese Bodenstation, die läuft aus in vier Jahren. Und wir müssen uns deswegen das einfahren lassen. Sie läuft aus deswegen, weil mobile Anwender diese Frequenz für sich haben wollen. Diese Anlage steht, das wissen Sie vielleicht nicht, wirklich inzwischen im Vorort von Perth. Perth ist eine sehr große Stadt, die extrem rapide wächst. Auch damit verbunden mit einer starken Interferenz der Wohngebiete und auch des Flughafens, was uns in jeder Menge Interferenzenprobleme verursacht. Aber eben noch entscheidender ist, dass die Lizenz für diese Anlage demnächst ausläuft. Wir müssen uns um eine Ersatzlösung bemühen. Ein Beispiel dafür ist eine Frequenzregulierung und eine Wanderung, die neue Frequenzbereiche für eine Agency sein können.
Das S-Band ist generell ein Bedrängnis. Heißt das, dass die gesamte Raumfahrt tendenziell in die X-Band-Richtung gehen will? Kann man das so sagen, dass der Trend zum X-Band geht?
Die ESA auf jeden Fall. Wir haben unsere Anlagen alle für X-Band hochgerüstet, für X-Band-TTNZ, also dieser 8 Gigahertz-Bereich. Und alle zukünftigen Wissenschaftsmissionen werden in diesem Bereich auch unterstützt werden, weil eben zukunftssicher ist, zwischentechnisch ausgereift. Und wir haben unseren Bedürfnissen hinreichend Anlagen selbst gebaut, die den Unterstützung liefern können. Jetzt die kommerziellen Raumfahrer, die machen das nicht. Die gehen weiterhin in den S-Bahn, weil es einfach kostengünstig ist. Und leben dann mit den Einschränkungen, die sie vielleicht haben, dass sie nicht überall hier Bodensstationen bauen können. Aber die wichtigen Vorteile eben, die Verfügbarkeit von S-Bahn-Anlagen weltweit zu günstigen Preisen, ist für die ein Argument, vorerst bei diesem Frequenzband zu bleiben.
Nachvollziehbar. Okay, also ich frage mich jetzt immer noch, wie groß besteht die Bodenstation? Man hat die Antenne, die Antenne definiert die Möglichkeiten, das Frequenzband definiert die Möglichkeiten und die Lage der Stationen definiert natürlich auch das angedachte Einsatzgebiet. Technisch sind sie vergleichbar, wenn auch nicht identisch. Man möchte es gerne so ähnlich wie möglich haben, damit es sich besser warten lässt. Was gehört jetzt noch dazu? Ist das jetzt im Wesentlichen diese Antenne oder gibt es noch andere wichtige Infrastrukturelemente, abgesehen jetzt natürlich von der Netzwerkanbindung?
Na gut, wir beschreiben die Hauptelemente der Anlage. Das sind natürlich die Antenne mit den ganzen Hochfrequenzeinrichtungen, damit verbunden sind Verstärker, Empfänger, Umsetzer. Dann gibt es im ZDF-Bereich, im niederfrequenten Bereich, Anlagen und Systeme, die dann die Signale umwandeln in Daten. Das sind z.B. dann Telemetrieprozessionen, die aus dem empfangenen Signal einen Datenstrom generieren, den entsprechend formatieren und über Protokolle, die definiert sind, dann an das Kontrollzentrum abliefern und in andere Richtungen genauso. Daneben, wie schon erwähnt, eine wichtige Funktion, die dann in den Geräten abgebildet ist, ist die Ranging- und Doppel-Einheit. Das heißt, es gibt über verschiedene Techniken die Möglichkeiten, einfach Laufzeitmessungen zu machen, zwischen Station und im orbit befindlichen Raumfahrzeug und zurück. Und über diese Wegmessung, das ist eine Laufzeitmessung, wird ein Signal oder ein Code geschickt und wieder empfangen. Über diese Laufzeitmessungen kann man dann eben die Entfernung zu diesem Zeitpunkt bestimmen und über viele Messungen dieser Art dann den Orbit berechnen. Gleichermaßen liefern wir auch Dopplermessungen, die man dann integriert und damit dann auch eine Bahnbestimmung durchführen kann. Das heißt, die Stationsleute, unser Geschäft, ist auch diese Messung der Ranging-Daten, der Messung der Doppler-Daten, die dann von den Bahnbestimmungsleuten in Orbit-Information umgewandelt werden.
Was ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen dieser Ranger-Messung und dieser Doppler-Messung? Also Doppler, vermute ich mal, bezieht sich auf den Doppler-Effekt. Also man misst quasi die Dehnung der Frequenz. Wie läuft das konkret ab? Also wie funktioniert das technisch, diese Messung?
Also die Laufzeitmessung, das ist relativ einfach. Man schickt ein Signal, empfängt es zurück und misst den Zeitpunkt.
Von wo empfängt man, weil ein Signal gesendet wird oder weil es reflektiert wird?
Also an Bord des Satelliten ist in der Regel ein kohärenter Transponder, der ein Signal empfängt, ist in der Frequenz umsetzt und zurückschickt. Und mit dieser Umsetzung erfolgt auch eine Umsetzung dieses Ranging-Signals. Typischerweise in unserem Fall ist das ein Code. Der Code wird empfangen, wird demoduliert, regeneriert und zurückgeschickt. Der Code wird am Boden wieder synchronisiert. Und die Zeit zwischen Wegschicken des Codes und Rückempfangen des Codes ist eine Laufzeit, die die Entfernung zwischen der Bodenstation und dem Satelliten mit einer sehr hohen Genauigkeit bestimmt.
Das setzt aber einen aktiv funktionierenden Satelliten voraus. Da muss etwas in Betrieb sein, um diese Antworten liefern zu können. Oder ist das so ein passives Element, das dadurch getriggert wird, dass es einfach ein Signal empfängt?
Das ist korrekt. Der Transponder muss funktionieren, muss das Signal zurückstecken. Je nachdem, es ist entweder ein regenerativer Prozess oder am einfachsten Falle wird einfach ein RF-Signal zurückgeschickt, das dann nur am Boden demoduliert wird. Aber der Kanal muss offen sein, das Satellit muss senden können. Und diese Transponderfunktion oder das regenerative Seugen des Signals muss aktiviert sein. Also man kann das nicht passiv machen. Es gibt Möglichkeiten, Satelliten auch in der Bahn auszumessen, indem man nur eine Wege-Techniken benutzt. Das ist ein One-Way-Doppler. Da braucht man nur ein Signal. Das Signal muss aus der Detail geschickt werden. Dadurch kann man über die Doppler-Messung eine Geschwindigkeitskomponente ermitteln. Das ist auch teilweise in der Bahnberechnung möglich.
Das heißt, man empfängt die Frequenz. Anhand der Dehnung der Frequenz kann man bestimmen, wie schnell sich der Satellit während dieses Sentences bewegt.
Der Doppler ist hier, vielleicht für die Zuhörer, die sich nicht mehr an den Physikunterricht erinnern. Der Doppler-Effekt beschreibt einfach die Ablage einer Welle aufgrund der Bewegung zwischen dem Empfänger und dem Sender dieser Welle.
Der Tatütata-Effekt.
Genau. Und in diesem Fall gibt es auch einen direkten linearen Bezug zwischen der Frequenz-Ablage, diesem Doppler, wie wir ihn nennen, und der Geschwindigkeit des Satelliten. Daraus kann man aus der Geschwindigkeit auch auf den Orbit-Zustand und zum Teil auch auf den Orbit selber schließen. Das ist aber nicht so mein Geschäft.
Wie kann man denn mit etwas kommunizieren, was jetzt nicht mehr aktiv sendet? Also wir hatten ja jetzt gerade den Fall des Rosat, der ja dann auch von Bodenstationen beobachtet worden ist. Der war aber komplett tot. Der hat ja keinen Mux mehr von sich gegeben. Da war keine Batterie, kein Computer mehr im Betrieb. Welche Möglichkeiten hat man an der Stelle, solche Objekte überhaupt noch einzufangen?
Also mit den ESTRACK-Stationen überhaupt nicht. Es gibt dann prinzipiell zwei Möglichkeiten. Sie können optische Teleskope das Ding tracken, wenn es beleuchtet ist. Das ist also ein übliches Verfahren. Man hat dann das Objekt verfolgt mit entsprechenden Teleskopen. Eine weitere Möglichkeit ist im erdnahen Bereich mit Radars. Im erdnahen Bereich können Sie Tag und Nacht bei jeder Gelegenheit, nicht nur wenn das Objekt beleuchtet ist, eben diese Objekte verfolgen, auch Bahnmessungen durchführen. Sie wissen ja, man kann schon Luftwaffe, hat dafür ein eigenes Netzwerk, für militärische Zwecke. Und gelegene Nuss- und Raumfahrtbehörden diese Fähigkeiten von NORAD, so heißt dieses Radarsystem, um Satelliten zu tracken, die ansonsten nicht erreichbar sind. Sei es, weil sie tot sind, ausgefallen, oder weil sie auf völlig unvorhergesinnten Bahnen kursieren, die man dann eben über die Antenneinrichtung nicht erkennen kann.
Beziehungsweise um den gesamten Weltraum überhaupt zu beobachten, was ja auch eine Aufgabe ist, die immer wichtiger wird. Das hatten wir hier bei Raumzeit auch schon ein paar Mal besprochen. Gut, aber vielleicht zurück zu ESTRACK. Also nur um es mal klar umrissen zu haben. Es handelt sich hier um ein Netzwerk von Bodenstationen. Es geht darum, aktiv in Betrieb befindliche Satelliten und Deep Space Missionen zu beobachten, mit ihnen zu kommunizieren. Vor allem möglichst permanent oder wann auch immer sie was senden. Telemetriedaten und natürlich auch Rohdaten, also Messdaten, wenn gerade was beobachtet wird, Fotos etc. übertragen werden, die zu empfangen. Jetzt bewegt sich ja die Erde die ganze Zeit. Es ist nachvollziehbar, dass man eigentlich permanent immer auf eine andere Bodenstation umschalten muss. Aber es kommuniziert eigentlich immer nur eine einzige Bodenstation mit einem Objekt da draußen? Oder ist das auch normaler Zustand, dass da mehrere gleichzeitig aktiv sind?
Sie haben vorhin den Effekt der Überlappung angesprochen. Also natürlich bei Satelliten, die weit genug weg sind von der Erde, haben der Regel mehr als eine unserer Anlagen Sichtkontakt zu diesen. Aber die Betriebsführung ist halt so, dass sie immer nur eine Station benutzen, um Kommandos zu schicken, das heißt, ein Uplink zu etablieren, während eben alle anderen das Signal empfangen, die Telemetrie empfangen und weiterleiten. Aber klar, immer nur einer soll senden, kann senden, um eben das Funktionieren des Uplinks zu gewährleisten. Jetzt bei Missionen, die sehr Erde nachfliegen, haben wir typische Kontaktzeiten von nur 10 Minuten, 8 bis 15 Minuten. Das heißt, wenn Sie da in einer kritischen Phase sind und zu dem Objekt dauerhaft Kontakt haben wollen, in einer polaren Mission, brauchen Sie eine Vielzahl von Stationen, um eben über diese kurzen Kontakte und in der Summe eine sehr weitreichende Kontaktwahrscheinlichkeit zu haben. Deswegen werden für diese Art von Missionen in der Launchphase, in der Startphase, in der Regel sehr viele Stationen aktiviert. 8 bis 10 hatten wir schon Stationen, die für diese Erdbeobachtungsmissionen, die im Polar umlaufen, den Kontakt bereitstellen. Jetzt für Missionen, die weit nach draußen fliegen. Der Klassiker waren früher die Geostationären-Missionen, die auf diesen geostationären Orbit gehen, der relativ weit draußen ist. Da haben sie auch in der Übergangsphase zwischen, nach dem Start bis der endgültige Orbit erreicht ist, in der Regel Kontaktphasen, die mehrere Stunden betragen. Das heißt, da reicht es auch aus, wenn sie eine Station haben, die momentan den Kontakt herstellt. In der Regel, aber aus betrieblichen Gründen, werden für Manöver, die man durchführt, die Anlagen immer so benutzt, dass man für die Manöverphase immer eine doppelte Abdeckung hat. Das heißt, zwei Stationen so gleich sehen den Satelliten. Eine wird fürs Kommandieren benutzt, aber beide sehen ihn und beide empfangen Telemetrie, um eben beim Ausfall einer Station immer noch einen Kontakt zu haben.
Wie häufig passiert das denn, dass eine Station ausfällt?
Relativ selten, es gibt es ja, relativ selten. In der Startphase weniger, weil in der Startphase werden natürlich die Stationen extrem vorbereitet, mit Mannschaft bestückt, mit Ersatzgeräten auch versorgt, die man einsetzen könnte. In der Routinephase kommt es ab und zu mal vor, dass eine Station nicht funktioniert, das heißt, dass der Antenne stehen bleibt aufgrund von mechanischen Problemen. Das heißt, dass der Sender ausfällt oder andere Probleme auftreten. Wir erfassen es natürlich in der Statistik und wir haben eine Verfügbarkeit unserer TTNC, also diese Telemetrie-Tracking und Unranging-Leistungen von mehr als 99 Prozent. Das heißt, in der überwiegenden Zahl der Stunden, die sie bei uns bestellen, an Verbindung zu ihrem Spacecraft, kriegen sie auch eine Verbindung hergestellt.
99 Prozent könnten ja immer noch drei Tage sein im Jahr, wo es nicht funktioniert. Das ist wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen mehr, oder?
Ja, das sind 99,8, 99,9 Prozent, wie man das genau deutet. Aber in der Regel sind es Naturverlässigkeiten, die für einen sicheren Betrieb der Satelliten völlig ausreichend sind.
Zumal man ja eben noch so viel Backup hat, aber generell gilt ja immer, doppelt hält besser und better safe than sorry als grundlegende Maßgabe hier eigentlich für solche Missionen. Diese Antennen, das sind ja jetzt eigentlich so diese ikonischen Antennen, die man so im Kopf hat. Also so riesige dicke Schüsseln, die sich, ich weiß nicht, so in so ziemlich jede Richtung bewegen können. Das sind ja ganz schöne Monstren. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt mal 35 Meter weiß, das größte. Da müssen ja schon mal extrem starke Motoren am Start sein, die das Ding halten. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass Wind da eine große Rolle spielt und sonstige Einflüsse, auch Wärmeausdehnung etc. Welche Rolle spielt das oder ist das alles problemlos und schon seit Langem beherrschte Technik?
Nein, natürlich diese großen, natürlich auch schweren Anlagen für diese Deep Space-Stationen, die haben natürlich diese von Ihnen angesprochenen Einschränkungen. Wir bewegen eben auch sehr langsam. Die Treckengeschwindigkeit von diesen Deep Space-Stationen, das heißt das Nachfolgen der Position im Weltraum, kann sehr langsam sein, weil in der Regel die Missionen, die mitgetreckt werden, relativ weit weg sind von der Erde und mit ganz geringen Geschwindigkeiten sich bewegen. Also die Treckengeschwindigkeit von unserer Anlage Indonesia, zum Beispiel in Australien, ist bis maximal 1 Grad pro Sekunde. Während die Anlagen, die für erdnähernden Naher-Emissionen eingesetzt werden, zum Beispiel die Polar-Emissionen, die diese schnelle Überflüge haben, die haben natürlich Treckengeschwindigkeiten, das heißt Nachführgeschwindigkeiten, mit denen sie das Objekt verfolgen, die sind 10-, 15-mal so hoch. Weil sie entsprechend dafür konzipiert sind. Das ist natürlich auch leichter. Aber auch ein anderes Frequenzband in der Regel, als eben diese ganz schweren, klobigen Deep Space-Anlagen.
Und woraus bestehen diese Antennen? Also was ist da sozusagen aufgetragen? Ist das jetzt irgendwie so eine Art Spiegel? Oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Gut, die Antennen-Spiegel an sich ist eine Stahlkonstruktion. Das ist also eine Stahlgerüst. Darauf werden dann die einzelnen Platten fixiert. Das ist also nicht aus einem Guss gebaut, sondern aus Stahlplatten, die zusammengefügt werden. Und die Präzision dieser Stahlkolosse muss eben so hoch sein, um mit diesen Frequenzen, die sie dann verarbeiten müssen, kompatibel zu sein. Das heißt, die Frequenz, die man einsetzt, desto höher muss die Oberflächengüte des Spiegels sein, um diese Reflektoreigenschaften, die man haben will, zu erfüllen. Eine starke Abweichung dieser einzelnen Paneele von der idealen Form, der Verunreinigung oder auch einer Verbiegung aufgrund von Masseproblemen, die den Reflexionskörper verformt, hat natürlich einen unmittelbaren Anfluss auf die elektrische Leistung dieser Antenne.
Aber es ist eigentlich jetzt nur so eine Stahlschicht, oder ist das irgendwie nochmal besonders oben versiegelt, nochmal mit irgendeinem anderen Material besprüht oder abgedeckt?
Nein, das ist eine Stahlkonstruktion, die natürlich dann mit einer Beschichtung versehen ist an der Oberfläche, um sie vor Korrosion zu schützen.
Ja, und die auch jetzt nur schützt, oder die jetzt auch für den Empfang der Signale noch eine besondere Eigenschaft hat?
Da müsst ich mal unseren Ingenieure-Experten fragen. Kann ich ihn so nicht sagen. Meines Wissens ist das primär Stahl, und der Anstrich ist als Schutz gedacht. Weil je nach Gebiet müssen sie die Antenne auch sehr oft streichen. Beispiel die Antenne in Kourou, in diesem feuchten Dschungelklima. Die wird sehr, sehr häufig gestrichen. Das hat deswegen auch den Spitznamen eines Fotomodells, weil es eben sehr oft gestrichen wird.
Muss regelmäßig nachgeschminkt werden sozusagen. Jetzt haben wir schon mehrfach darauf hingewiesen, alles ist miteinander vernetzt. Teil von ESTRACK ist eben nicht nur die Bodenstation als solche, sondern auch die Verbindung untereinander. Was existiert da? Wie sind die miteinander verbunden? Es soll schnell gehen und zuverlässig sein. Man wünscht sich auch eine gewisse Stabilität und politische Sicherheit, was diese Standorte betrifft. Das gilt natürlich auch für die Wege untereinander. Was nützt einem eine Bodenstation, die ein Objekt tatsächlich empfängt, aber nicht in der Lage ist, diese Daten auch dahin zu liefern, wo man sie braucht?
Die Anlagen sind alle verboten, wie schon am Anfang angedeutet, durch Bodenleitungen mit Darmstadt. Das heißt, es ist ein Spinnennetzsystem, wo die Anlagen nicht untereinander, sondern mit einem zentralen Punkt, die an Darmstadt verbunden sind. Diese Verbindungen, zurück zum ESOC, sind immer redundant. Man hat immer zwei Leitungen, die diese Verbindung herstellen. Die sind auch divers geroutet. Das heißt, die Leitungen sind nicht im gleichen Seekabel oder nicht über den gleichen Satelliten, sondern haben verschiedene Routen, die erst hier in der ESOC zusammengeführt werden.
Das heißt, die Signale zweier Bodenstationen kreuzen sich nie. Treffen eigentlich erst hier über vollständig physikalisch separate Leitungen auf?
Na gut, also jeder Station hat ihre eigene Verbindung zurück nach Darmstadt. Diese Verbindung ist in sich noch mal redundant. Das heißt, jeder Station hat zwei Leitungen mit Darmstadt. Es gibt eine Ausnahme, aber das ist die Regel im gesamten ESTRACK-Netzwerk. Die Leitungen haben Kapazitäten in der Regel von 2 bis 10 Megabit. Zukunft auch mehr. Ich glaube, wir haben noch zwei Leitungen, die haben nur 256 Kilobit. Das sind Leitungen, die wir... Also wir haben ein privates Firmen-Netzwerk, ein IP-Network. Wir haben unseren eigenen Router und Fireballs, die mit diesen Mietleitungen oder anderen Verbindungen dann verknüpft werden zu einem eigenen Netz, nennt sich Opsnet. Das wird eben benutzt zur Verbindung dieser Station mit dem Zentrum hier. Sie tragen natürlich zum einen diese TUNC-Daten, die wir angesprochen haben, also Telemetrie, Telekommando, aber auch Sachen wie Voice, die Sprachkommunikation mit den Operators vor Ort, auch die Steuerungssignale für die Anlagen und andere Hilfsfunktionen.
Das klingt jetzt so 2 Megabit nicht unbedingt nach einer üppigen Ausstattung.
Das ist auch richtig, weil die meisten älteren Wissenschaftsmissionen relativ geringe Datenratenansprüche haben. Das ist anders, wenn sie auf eine Erdbeobachtungsmission konzipieren müssen. Die Erdbeobachtungsmissionen, die in der Regel Imaging-Devices haben, optische Sensoren, die die Erde beobachten, damit sehr viel Bildmaterial erzeugen, laden diese Daten ab über den Stationen mit mehreren 100 Megabit pro Sekunde. Die müssen dann nach dem Passage zurückgeführt werden für die jeweiligen Bildverarbeitungszentren. Da haben sie dann natürlich deutlich höhere Datenratenanforderungen. Aber die meisten der Kunden, die wir haben in der ESOC, sind Wissenschaftsmissionen. Die können mit Datenraten bis zu 2-10 Megabit sehr gut leben. Die Missionen sind auch zum Teil vor 15, 20 Jahren konzipiert worden. Damals konzipiert eben für Bodennetze, die realisierbar waren. Zukunftige Wissenschaftsmissionen, GAIA ist ein Beispiel für die ESA, die haben Datenratenansprüche von 10 Megabit und mehr.
Das heißt, die Bodenschleizungen müssen auch in der Lage sein, Daten zwischendurch zu speichern. Die empfangen das alles, speichern das erstmal weg. Allein schon für den Fall, dass wirklich mal das Problem ist, dass trotz redundanter Auslegung eine Leitung nicht funktioniert. Aber so dass man eben auch sagen kann, wir beobachten das Ding jetzt für 10 Minuten, dann übernimmt sowieso jemand anders. Aber die Daten, die wir in dem Zeitraum empfangen haben, die sehen wir dann sozusagen danach wieder, wenn Platz ist.
In der Regel ist da wie gesagt die Station selber und das Bodennetz redundant ausgelegt. Das heißt, ein Ausfall, der gelingen nicht vorkommt, hat eigentlich keinen Anfluss auf den Datentransfer. Aber natürlich können die Anlagen auch in ihrem Backend die Daten zwischenspeichern. Eine Woche, zwei Wochen können sie diese Wissenschaftsdaten dort lokal vorhalten und notfalls die zurückspielen, falls die Bodenleitungen ausfallen sollten. Das kommt gedinglich vorher.
Aber heißt das jetzt, dass wirklich jede Bodenstation seine eigene Leitung hat, die so quer durch den Ozean geht, vollkommen unabhängig von allem anderen? Oder nutzt man da auch existierende Datentransferwege, die jetzt auch für andere Verbindungen genutzt werden?
Also es stimmt, jede Station hat ihre eigene Verbindung von der Station zur ESOC. Und natürlich werden diese nicht für uns gelegt. Wir leben da kein Seekabel. Wir mieten diese Leitungen von kommerziellen Providern. Die Telekom zum Beispiel ist ja bekannt oder andere, die uns dann diese Verbindung zur Verfügung stellen. Das heißt, wir benutzen bestehende Infrastruktur von ganz normalen kommerziellen Telekom-Anbietern.
Aber dann eben mit garantierter Bandbreite und vor allem auch mit einer garantierten Verfügbarkeit.
Früher hatten wir eine echte Least-Line. Heutzutage haben wir garantierte Bandbreite in Verfügbarkeit. Und das ist sozusagen, was wir mieten. Also Rohmaterial, um dann darauf aufzubauen, ein IP-Netzwerk selbst zu basteln, mit eigenen Routern und einer eigenen Kontrolleinheit.
Um das jetzt alles zu koordinieren, da ist ja jetzt organisatorisch eine Menge dahinter. Man hat viele Bodenstationen, man hat vor allem, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Missionen werden so gleichzeitig von dem ESTRACK-Netz beobachtet? Wie viele, wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Sind das immer nur so ein paar oder sind das gleichzeitig ganz viele?
Also momentan haben wir in der Routinephase 10 Missionen, die wir momentan hier vom ESTRACK aus betreiben. Es sind 13 Satelliten. Eine Mission hat 4 Satelliten, das ist eine Cluster-Mission. Die fliegen momentan und werden Tag und Nacht von hier kontrolliert und betreut. Wir haben weiterhin momentan 3 externe Missionen, für die wir Stationsdienste anbieten. Für Eumetzat, Eumetzat ist hier in Darmstadt, Europäische Wetter-Metrologie-Organisation für die Raumfahrt. Wir haben auch Kunden in Amerika, für die wir ESTRACK-Daten, Estracking-Services erzeugen und verkaufen. Das heißt, wir haben momentan 13 Missionen und 16 Satelliten, die wir unterstützen. Das ist sozusagen die Dauerlast. Hinzu kommt, was für uns eigentlich hier ein sehr großer Aufwand ist, die Vorbereitung von Missionen. In der Vorbereitung von Missionen haben wir auch, was diese Datenleitungen anbetrifft, Verbindungen zu Test-Centers, zu irgendwelchen Check-Out-Plätzen, von denen Verbindungen zwischen den Satelliten z.B. und dem halbwertigen Kontrollzentrum hergestellt werden, um bestimmte Tests zu fahren.
Und wie viele Leute arbeiten dann auf einer Bodenstation? Und wie viele Leute sind hier in Darmstadt gleichzeitig dabei, diese Daten auch anzunehmen?
Also vor Ort haben wir pro Station so eine typische Mannschaftsgröße von 8 bis 15 Personen, je nach dem Schwank von Ort zu Ort.
Also insgesamt oder gleichzeitig am Werk?
Da ist eine Mannschaft, die ist vor Ort und in der Regel sind die da während der normalen Arbeitszeit. Das heißt 40 Stunden die Woche für Maintenance sind die zuständig. Daneben wurde in der Vergangenheit diese Mannschaft auch eingesetzt, um Betrieb zu machen. Das heißt bei kritischen Startphasen typischerweise, war dann die Mannschaft vor Ort auch da rund um die Uhr während der kritischen Phasen, um den Betrieb der Anlage lokal zu betreiben unter Voice-Control hier vom ESOC. Das heißt es gab hier jemand, der hat einfach über das Intercom die Leute angewiesen, welche Operationen sie vor Ort ausführen sollen. Das hat sich vor Jahren geändert. Wir sind jetzt dabei auch in diesen kritischen Phasen. Alle ESA-Stationen von hier aus zentral zu steuern, zu konfigurieren. Das heißt die Mannschaften vor Ort haben inzwischen eine reduzierte Rolle. Eine reine Maintenance-Rolle. Diese halten auch in der Regel diese 40 Stunden pro Woche ausführen. Und eben reingerufen werden nachts, wenn irgendwas ausfällt, oder woanders, gibt eine Rufbereitschaft. Dann kommen die rein, wechseln Geräte aus, reparieren was, machen ein Reset. Und die werden auch dann eben angesetzt in den kritischen Startphasen als Permanentpräsenz, um vor Ort dann, wenn was schiefgeht, sofort eingreifen zu können.
Das heißt, eigentlich sind diese Bodenstationen ferngesteuert, hier von Darmstadt aus, kann man so sagen.
Die sind seit knapp zehn Jahren eigentlich komplett ferngesteuert und inzwischen auch vollautomatisiert. Das heißt, die werden hier von zwei Leuten rund um die Uhr das gesamte Netzwerk überwacht. Und der Betrieb an sich läuft vollautomatisch. Vollautomatisch heißt es, die Betriebsingenieure, die erarbeiten für ihre jeweiligen Missionen eine Timeline, also eine Sequenz von Konfigurationskommandos, die in Stationen geladen werden, einen wöchentlichen Rhythmus. Und diese Timelines führen dann nach eben noch vorbestimmten Zeitschritten die Operationen aus. Und in der Regel ist da kein Eingreifen erforderlich.
Das heißt, da gibt es einen zentralen Computer, bzw. er wird wahrscheinlich auch noch wieder diverse Backups haben, naheliegend, der eigentlich die Antenne führt, der auch immer genau weiß, mit welchem Frequenzband er mit welchem Satelliten zu reden hat, etc., Das heißt aber im Umkehrschluss auch, dass das hier ja auch alles erfasst werden muss, programmiert werden muss. Und was ist das für ein Aufwand? Also ist das so alles extrem vorhersehbar? Weiß man schon jetzt auf Wochen und Monate im Voraus, was eigentlich so zu tun ist? Oder gibt es auch einen hohen Anteil von Kurzfristigkeit, dass sich Dinge ändern?
Also in der Regel werden die gesamten Routineoperationen vorgeplant. Wir haben diesen Wochenrhythmus erwähnt. Das gilt für die polaren Missionen. Das sind die Missionen, die am kurzfristigsten oder am wenigsten lange vorausplanen können oder wollen aufgrund ihrer Missionseigenschaften. Missionen, die die Wissenschaft betreiben, sind in der Regel über drei bis vier Monate vorausplanbar. Und diese Deep Space Missionen, die sind extrem stabil. Da kann man die Stationsnutzung, was unser Geschäft ist, zum Teil bis in ein Jahr vorausplanen. Was wir machen, sind regelmäßige Sitzungen, erstellen die Pläne, die dann umgewandelt werden, in dann immer verfeinerte Detailpläne, bis sie dann eben in diesem, wir nennen das ESTRACK Ground Segment Schedule umgewandelt werden, denn für die gesamten ESTRACK Stationen die detaillierte Kommandosequenz erzeugt, um für die jeweiligen Passagen, die dann vorprogrammiert sind, die Stationen aufzusetzen und den Betrieb auszuführen. Späte Änderungen, die diesen einmal gemachten Plan betreffen, gibt es relativ selten. Es sind weniger als zehn Prozent. Da sieht man noch nach diesem Planungsrhythmus, die Stationsnutzung abgeändert wird. Also wir haben da relativ stabile Kunden. Wenn man eben diese drei Familien unterscheidet, die Familie der Polarmission, die nur zehn Tage im Voraus planen kann oder will, die Wissenschaftsmission mit drei bis vier Monaten und daneben die für uns extrem stabilen Deep Space Missionen, die sehr träge oder lang vorhersehbar planen.
Da kann ja jetzt jeder kommen und sagen, das ist alles hier auf ein Jahr lang vorausplanbar. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es dann auch eine Menge unerwartetes gibt. Ich meine, Notsituationen jetzt auf Satelliten, die nicht erreichbar sind, etc. Wie läuft da eigentlich? Ist das eigentlich eine Aufgabe von ESTRACK, so etwas auch festzustellen? Oder wird sowas dann erst von den eigentlichen Teams festgestellt, die quasi am Ende dieser Datenleitung sind, dass nichts mehr läuft? Also kümmert man sich wirklich jetzt nur um diese Weiterleitung? Oder ist das ESTRACK schon soweit involviert, dass so viel Verhalten festgestellt werden kann?
Na gut, das ESTRACK ist natürlich wirklich dieser Teil in diesem Gesamtverfahren, der die Verbindung zwischen dem Kontrollzentrum und dem Setup herstellt. Wenn die irgendwie gestört ist, zum Beispiel, weil es im Safe Mode geht oder weil irgendwas an Bord nicht stimmt, hat es natürlich Konsequenzen für diese Stationslayer. Man kann es da ja erkennen zum Teil, aber ESTRACK kann nicht die Ursache von Fehlern erkennen oder gar nicht korrigieren. Klasse ist, wenn der Satellit in Safe Mode geht, also ein Problem hat und sich aus dem normalen Zustand verabschiedet, ist das in der Regel verbunden mit einer Veränderung der Datenrate. Das heißt, auf einmal stellen wir fest, ob das Signal ist weg oder es ist noch da, aber eine ganz andere Datenrate. Wir haben dann in der Regel vor programmierte Sequenzen, wie man das dann feststellt. Wenn man feststellt, der Ersatz von der Datenrate ist weg runter, auf wie sie Minimalrate in der Regel im Safe Mode gestalten wird. Das ist ein Indiz, das Ding ist in Safe Mode. Da gibt man halt die Alarmglocke bei den Leuten, die die Mission selbst betreiben. Die machen dann eine weitere Untersuchung. Sehr oft ist natürlich ESTRACK hilfreich, weil wir bei Problemen z.B. im Tetuan-Seesystem des Satelliten, wenn da Probleme auftreten, sind natürlich die Expertise der Leute, die Stationen betreiben und den Spacelink insgesamt sehr gut kennen, sehr oft dann wichtig, um dieses Problem zu verstehen und auch zu lösen. Aber wie gesagt, ESTRACK ist eines dieser Bausteine im Gesamtbetriebskonzept des Zentrums.
Und wie viel funktioniert dann quasi die letzte Meile? Also wenn die Daten erstmal hier in Darmstadt aufgeschlagen sind, werden die dann so transparent weiter zu den eigentlichen Teams für die Missionen weitergeleitet? Sind die dann auch hier vor Ort präsent oder sind die dann vielleicht nochmal ganz woanders?
Also in der Regel ist das ESOC hier zuständig für den Betrieb des Satelliten an Sicht der Plattform. Die Nutzlastdatenverarbeitung ist nicht in den Mandat dieses Zentrums. Das heißt, deswegen werden wir die Daten einsammeln und weiterleiten. Die Plattformdaten werden hier benutzt von den Leuten, die die Plattform steuern. Also das ist Lage-Regelungskommando, Orbitbestimmung, Zustandsbestimmung des Satelliten, Növerplanung. Aber die Nutzlastdaten an Sicht der Instrumente an Bord, die gehen dann in die verschiedenen Einrichtungen, die diese Daten dann verarbeiten. Die Wissenschaftsdaten der ESA werden, das wissen Sie bestimmt, in Spanien verarbeitet, in dem dortigen Zentrum der ESA für wissenschaftliche Datenverarbeitung. Die Erdbeobachtungsdaten der ESA-Missionen werden in der Regel von Esrin aus in Italien, einem anderen ESA-Zentrum verarbeitet und dort verwaltet. Das heißt, wir besplitten die Daten auf, in die die hier bleiben, für unsere Leute, die die Mission betreiben, und die Daten, die nutzlastbezogen sind, die dann weitergeleitet werden an die jeweiligen Nutzer der Wissenschaftsmission an sich. Das Konzept des LKWs, der LKW wird von hier aus betrieben. Wir schicken das Ding in den Weltraum, packen da Instrumente drauf. Das heißt, der LKW bringt diese Wissenschaftsmission in den Weltraum. Die Wissenschaftsmission an sich wird eben nicht vom ESOC hier, sondern von anderen Leuten genutzt und geplant und betrieben.
Aber schiefgehen kann ja immer irgendwas. Wenn ich mir so vorstelle, dass da einfach so eine Antenne einsam ihre Kreise zieht, jetzt abgesehen von den Abnutzungserscheinungen, die man ja quasi einplanen kann, bei solchen komplexen Geräten könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass da immer mal wieder Unvorhergesehenes passiert, insbesondere an so fernen Orten. Gut, ich meine, die eine Station ist jetzt direkt an Perth. Das ist ja schon geradezu urbanes Gebiet, aber der Rest steht ja relativ weit draußen. Was nicht. Machen sich da nicht Tiere breit auf der Antenne und bauen da ihre Nester?
Ja, gibt es zum Beispiel ein Problem. In Spanien, wo die ESA Deep Space Station steht, haben wir ein Problem mit den Vögeln, die sich da einnisten. Deswegen gibt es zum Beispiel ein Falkner, der kommt und diese Vögel jagt mit so einem Raubvogel, der die dann klein hält und verjagt. Damit da halt nicht zu viele Schäden entstehen in den Hochfrequenzanlagen der Antenne.
Ah, das heißt, der schickt einfach seinen Vogel los und der hält sich da sozusagen.
Er treibt die Vögel, die hinterlassen schaffen. Oder andere Tiere. In Australien haben wir natürlich Kängurus, die da gelegentlich auftauchen. Aber noch schlimmer sind die Buschfeuer. In Australien ist das ein Problemgebiet, was Brände anbelangt. Und wir hatten schon Feuer, die waren sehr nahe bei der Station. Aber dann ist die Sorge groß, dass es übergreifen könnte auf die Anlage. Andere Tierprobleme haben wir, weil sie jetzt bei Tieren sind. Es gibt Mäuse, die sich irgendwo einigen. Kuro ist ja eine sehr feuchte Gegend. Die Mäuse mögen die Anlage gerne und kommen da rein. Sie setzen sich dann fest in den Schränken und Kabelbäumen. Das ist auch nicht so angenehm. Dann gibt es eine Kurzschlüsse und ganz komische Effekte.
Wie ausfallsicher ist denn dann so eine Station? Sind das jetzt so minore Probleme? Oder hat es jetzt auch ein Vieh schon mal geschafft, die Bodenstation aus dem Tritt zu bringen?
In Kuro gab es mal einen größeren Kurzschluss wegen einer Maus, die in einem Kabelbaum verendet ist. Ich war mal in Australien vor vielen Jahren. Da war das eher ein Problem beim Aufbau. Da waren wir in Parks. Parks ist eigentlich ein Radioteleskop der Australier. Das wurde mal eine Zeit lang umgebaut für eine Benutzung als reine Empfangsantenne für eine Kometenmission. Da waren wir unten ein Vierteljahr zum Aufbau. Und irgendwann sind Schlangen entdeckt worden, die da gerne reinkamen in diesen Raum. Und dann gab es noch die große Panik. Und keiner wollte dann diese Kabelbäume aufmachen und die Schlangen suchen. Da wurde dann extra ein Schlangenfänger geholt, der das relativ schnell an die Tiere rausgeholt hat. Dann haben wir entsprechende Maßnahmen, haben den Griff in die Tücher abgeschlossen. Dann kamen die nicht mehr rein und konnten in Ruhe arbeiten. Das waren die kleineren Sachen.
Und wie gerüstet ist das System gegen Ausfälle? Man plant alles im Voraus. Man weiß ganz genau, welche Station auf welches Objekt gerichtet ist. Dann kommt das Buschfeuer oder die Kängurus-Hopsten auf der Antenne rum. Und so eine Bodenstation kann in dem Moment nicht mehr liefern. Es kann ja so eine Mission auch gefährden, insbesondere wenn sie sich gerade in einem kritischen Kommandomoment befindet. Irgendeine Deep Space-Mission soll jetzt mal auf Hibernation gesetzt werden, wie bei Rosetta, muss in Rotation gebracht werden. Das sind ja dann auch extrem zeitkritische Operationen, wo man nicht sagen kann, naja, wenn es jetzt nicht geklappt hat, machen wir das morgen noch mal oder nächste Woche. Sondern es klappt halt jetzt, oder es klappt vielleicht gar nicht.
Ja, das kommt extrem selten vor. Sie wissen ja, die Anlagen sind an sich redundant ausgelegt, was schon ein großer Schutz ist. Diese 99,9 Prozent haben wir schon erwähnt. Hinzu kommt, dass in diesen kritischen Phasen ja Leute vor Ort sind, die bei Problemen relativ schnell reagieren können. Und hinzu kommt, dass die Stationen wie gesagt nur ein Baustein sind im Gesamtkonzept. Das heißt, bei kritischen Manövern ist es eine Regel so, dass man mehrere Stationen zugleich hat. Das ist immer so beim Start. Bei Phasen wie z.B. Orbit Insertion, wenn eine Probe sich irgendwo, z.B. Mars oder Venus Orbit einschießt, hat man immer zwei Stationen, die während dieser Phase Unterstützung leisten.
Welche Gegenarbeit muss denn... Dass die Bodenstationen dann in der Lage sind, die Arbeit eines anderen zu übernehmen, das ist ja das eine. Aber ist es auch immer problemlos so, dass es den Objekten da oben egal ist, wer mit ihnen redet? Also, prüfen die eigentlich in irgendeiner Form, wer da mit ihnen quatscht oder gehen die davon aus, na ja, hier kommt irgendwie X-Band ins All, das wird schon stimmen? Also, wissen die, mit wem sie es zu tun haben? Wissen die Objekte da draußen, mit welcher Station sie gerade reden und sind sie sich dessen quasi bewusst?
Also, ähnlich wie ein Mobiltelefon, mit dem können sie auch von Zelle zu Zelle gehen. Sie haben eine Verbindung und ihnen ist es eigentlich egal, ob es der Sender A oder Sender B aktiv ist. So ist man in Stationen im Prinzip auch. Die Stationen sind alle, die für die Mission vorbereitet sind, sind alle in der Lage, gleichermaßen mit der Mission zu kommunizieren. Natürlich darf immer nur eine senden. Aber das wird am Boden von der Gruppe geregelt, die die Stationen gesamthaft betreibt. Aber natürlich ist es schon ganz wichtig, was sie angesprochen haben. Pro Mission, aber auch insgesamt für die Raumfahrtbehörde, für unsere Agency, ist es ganz wichtig, eine Anlage zu bauen, das ESTRACK, so zu konzipieren, dass es mit allen Missionen der ESA kommunizieren kann. Wir wollen keine Lösung, die nur mit der Mission A funktioniert, und nicht mit der Mission B. Um das zu garantieren, haben alle Raumfahrtbehörden der Welt verschiedene Komitees gegründet. Das bekannteste ist CCSDS, eine dieser Standardisierungsgruppen, die weltweit Standards erarbeitet, damit alle wichtigen Aspekte, die so einen Cross-Support betreffen, das sind Sachen wie Frequenzen, Modulationsverfahren, Datenformate, Protokolle, dass sie weltweit einem gemeinsamen Standard folgen, um eben dann die NASA-Mission, die russische Mission von der ESA unterstützen zu lassen, genauso wie andersrum. Und das ist inzwischen weltweit sehr, sehr gut gelungen, gerade in diesem Frequenzbereich. S-Brain, was wir angesprochen haben, das ist ein weltweit extrem standardisiertes Frequenzband mit den darunterliegenden Funktionen, wo man inzwischen eigentlich problemlos weltweit diese Station nutzen kann, auch relativ spontan bei Problemen zum Beispiel.
Das heißt, es gibt so eine Art Satelliten-Esperanto, man redet eigentlich mit allen Objekten mehr oder weniger die gleiche Sprache. Es gibt dann nur Unterschiede in dem, was man dann konkret sagen kann.
Der Dialektakzent ist verschieden von Agency zu Agency, aber das Grund war Corolla und Grammatik ist der gleiche. Und es klappt eigentlich seit Jahren sehr gut. Das ist für uns natürlich auch eine wichtige Aufgabe hier im Zentrum, weil wir an dieser Standardisierung mitarbeiten. Wir erstellen die Standards, wir bauen die nachher auch nach in unseren Anlagen, genauso wie die NASA, die Franzosen, die Deutschen, die Russen zum Teil, die Japaner. Und schaffen damit eben diesen Standard, dieses Esperanto, das sie angesprochen haben.
Aber in dem Moment, wo ein Satellit entwickelt wird, das ist ja meist eine lange Zeit, an welcher Stelle, also tritt während der Entwicklung das ESTRACK selbst auch schon in Aktionen? Und gibt es Testphasen, wo diese Kommunikation dann auch konkret durchexerziert wird? Begleitet das die Entwicklung die ganze Zeit? Oder ist das schon so gut standardisiert, dass das schon auch von jemand anders geprüft werden kann?
Also die Anfangsphase, das ist Involvement von ESTRACK praktisch über die Standards. Das heißt, die Missionen, die wollen auch im Kostenzusparen natürlich standardisiert bauen. Das heißt, die machen diese Standards applicable für ihre Ausschreibungen, für ihre Designarbeit. Deswegen kommt da schon in der Phase A und Phase B und so weiter normalerweise Produkte raus, die ESTRACK-kompatibel sein sollen. Das ist das Ziel auch, um die Kosten im vernünftigen Rahmen zu halten. Der erste große Test, auf dem wirklich so ist natürlich, ist in der Regel erst 2 Jahre vom Start. 1,5-2 Jahre vom Start gibt es einen sehr wichtigen Test, den Hochfrequenz-Kompatibilitätstest hier in der ESOC. Und mit Hilfe einer Replika des Satelliten und einer Referenzstation, die alle ESTRACK-Stationen abbildet, geprüft wird, ist diese Replika und diese Referenzstation wirklich kompatibel. Passen die Frequenzen, sind die Pegel richtig, sind die Datenformate richtig eingestellt?
Was heißt alle abbildet? Also sie kann sich verhalten wie jede einzelne dieser zehn Stationen?
Ja, aufgrund dieser Harmonisierung, die wir anstreben...
Sind die einfach schon so ähnlich?
Die Referenzstation ist die Repräsentativ für die Gesamtheit der ESTRACK-Station. Und deswegen gilt die als...
Aber es wird hier sozusagen real ein Satellitenmodell konkret über Funk verbunden mit dieser Referenzstation.
Ja, also wir kriegen da einen sogenannten Suitcase geliefert, das ist ein Koffer. Das ist also in der Regel ein rollbares Rack. Das beinhaltet designgleiche Teile in den Satelliten, in der Regel den Transponder, ein Teil der Anbord-Data-Handling-Unit, die also diese Datenformate erzeugt. Und diese wird über eine Funkstrecke, in der Regel ist das einfach ein Kabel. Die Antenne haben wir nicht da, verbunden über eine RF-Strecke, verbunden mit der entsprechenden Referenzstation. Das heißt, man spielt da Telemetrie über S-Band oder X-Band runter in die Station unter verschiedenen Verhältnissen, die simuliert werden, Störverhältnisse, Abweichungen, nicht-nominales Verhalten, und gewinnt da einen ersten, sehr umfangreichen Eindruck über die, wie weit dieses gebaute System den Spezifikationen entspricht und wie weit es mit ESTRACK wirklich kompatibel ist.
Ich nehme an, da gibt es dann auch so eine definierte Test-Suite, die dann durchgelaufen wird, die man dann einfach testet.
Ja, das ist auch ein weltweiter Standard. Eine Testfolgen, die man da durchführt.
Das ist auch ein Zufallsfaktor. Also meistens bei Software immer so, wenn man selbst eine Test-Suite gibt, dann ist immer alles super. Weil man ja mit der Test-Suite die ganze Zeit getestet hat, dann geht dann halt die Test-Suite. Aber in dem Moment, wo die Dinge dann anders sind, kommt ja auch schnell mal was durcheinander. Sitzt da einer und hackt einfach mal wild auf der Tastatur rum und guckt, was dann passiert?
Wir haben in der Regel zwei Stufen. Wenn das Gerät hierher kommt, dieser Suitcase, ist der ja schon abgenommen. Das heißt, es gibt eine Abnahme beim Entwickler, der guckt, ist das Gerät so, wie es Papier beschrieben hat. Was wir hier machen, ist eine Validierung zum Teil. Wir gucken dann, ob dieses Gerät, wie gebaut, mit ESTRACK wie gebaut funktioniert. Da werden immer Abweichungen festgestellt. Das sind meistens Kleinigkeiten, aber wir haben noch nie einen Test gehabt, der völlig 100% kompatibel ist. Immer kleine Abweichungen, Überraschungen. Entweder das Fehler gemacht worden im Design, oder dass die Konfiguration, die wir vorgesehen haben, nicht optimal ist oder irgendwelche Missverständnisse.
Also ohne den Test würde es katastrophal werden?
Der Test ist vital für unser Geschäft. Das ist eigentlich auch nie verhandelbar, weil es auch nicht Kosten verursacht. Das ist aber ganz entscheidend, weil im Gegensatz zu einem Kommunikationssatelliten, der Bilder oder Nachrichten verteilt, ist ja so ein TTC-Link sozusagen die Lifeline, die Nabelschnur, an dem die Mission fliegt. Wenn der versagt, ist die ganze Mission nicht mehr steuerbar. Deswegen macht es Sinn, diesen großen Aufwand vor dem Start zu treiben, um dieses Interface sehr gründlich, sehr umfassend zu testen, zu verifizieren.
Aber diese Funkstrecke als solche, der Transponder, der wird aber auch noch mal getestet, dann bei ESA-Missionen, vermutlich beim STEC?
Ja klar, der Selber wird in verschiedenen Stufen getestet, in der Testchamber auch oder auch simuliert, um halt die Charakteristika dieses Transponders und auch der Antennen, die da noch dran hängen, genau zu bestimmen. Wir machen auch gelegentlich, das ist dann hier aus der betrieblichen Ecke manchmal erwünscht, noch einen letzten Test auf dem Launchpad. Wenn das Ding jetzt auf dem Launchpad sitzt, dann wird einfach eine Funkstrecke etabliert zwischen dem Launchpad und der Station. Da wird der Launchpad an diesem großen Gebäude zusammengebaut. Es wird einfach eine Funkstrecke etabliert zwischen dem Satelliten auf dem Launchpad und der KORU-Station, die nicht weit weg ist. Funktioniert das, sind die Parameter richtig gesetzt. Natürlich ist die Leistung dann nicht ganz repräsentativ, aber alle anderen Parameter kann man relativ gut verifizieren.
Das heißt, auch da könnte im letzten Moment noch ein Missionsabbruch eingeleitet werden?
Ja, oder eine Umkonfiguration der Regel.
Ist das schon mal passiert?
Nein, bisher nicht. Aber es gibt ein gutes Gefühl, man weiß, das Ding, wie es da oben setzt, ist im Prinzip funktionsfähig.
Ja, natürlich. ESTRACK ist jetzt das Netzwerk der ESA. Andere Organisationen dürften ihre eigenen Bodenstationsnetzwerke haben. Einige Stationen der NASA haben wir ja schon angesprochen. Ist denn das Bodenstationsnetzwerk nur mit Darmstadt verbunden? Oder gibt es auch in irgendeiner Form, anders gefragt, ist ESTRACK überhaupt mit anderen Bodenstationen auch noch vernetzt, die jetzt nicht von der ESA sind? Und von welcher Art ist diese Verbindung, wenn es sie gibt?
Also alle Netzwerkbetreiber haben diesen zentralen Approach. Das heißt, sie steuern das Netzwerk von einem Punkt aus. Und da ist auch der Eintritt in dieses Netzwerk. Wir gewähren natürlich externen Nutzern, auch die ESTRACK-Service, über einen Entry-Point, der hier in der ESA ist. Das heißt, die NASA klassischerweise, die CNES, die französische Raumfahrtbehörde, die kennen über eine Leitung, die zwischen deren Zentren und uns besteht, sich hier in das ESTRACK einwählen, sozusagen, und unsere Dienstleistungen nutzen. Das machen eigentlich alle Raumfahrtagenturen so. Die Nutzung direkter Stationen, dass man sich dort direkt einwählen, das ist nicht vorgesehen aus Sicherheitsgründen und aus praktischen Gründen der Konfigurationskontrolle.
Aber das heißt auch, dass so eine Verbindung automatisiert fest hergestellt werden kann. Ich stelle mir vor, die NASA hätte jetzt irgendeine Mission, es läuft irgendwas schief und aus welchen Gründen auch immer kann das Bodenstationsnetzwerk der NASA in dem Moment nicht die Informationen generieren, die erforderlich sind. Dann dürfte es ja auch mehr oder weniger automatisierte Prozeduren geben, die dann initiiert werden müssen. Kann dann die NASA sich quasi über das ESOC mehr oder weniger direkt mit den Bodenstationen verbinden und genauso diese Kommandos einspielen, wie man das normalerweise von Darmstadt aus tun würde?
In der Regel muss man das inwiefern validieren. Wir gucken, ob alles konfiguriert ist wie gewünscht. Aber wenn das mal gemacht ist, halten wir hier einige Konfigurationen vor. Für die NASA, für die französische Raumfahrtbehörde, für die deutsche Raumfahrtbehörde, um eben im Notfall ganz kurzfristig diese Verbindung aktivieren zu können. Ja, das ist möglich.
Wenn das häufiger stattfinde, hat das überhaupt schon mal stattgefunden?
Ja, wir hatten das schon gelegentlich. Der letzte war, glaube ich, ein japanischer Hilferuf. Das war wirklich ein Hilferuf. Die hatten, man das vor zwei Jahren, irgendeine Mission im kritischen Zustand und hatten dann über so einen Emergency-Aufruf unsere Dienste angefordert. In der Regel ist das nicht ganz so panisch. Es kommt dann über einen geordneten Weg, das heißt über einen Kontaktpunkt, der vorher vereinbart wurde. Man macht normalerweise Pre-Agreements und testet das Zeug aus. Wir haben das schon mit der Knessen-Agreement. Wir haben in Kuroe zwei Stationen, die ESA-Stationen, die wir schon beschrieben haben. Nicht weit davon weg eine Französische Station neben dem Launchpad. Und wir haben mit der Vereinbarung, dass wir, wenn unsere Station ausfällt, von deren Stationen praktisch Backup-Service bekommen. Wir haben das eingerichtet, ausgetestet, konfiguriert. Es ist noch Point-of-Contact identifiziert worden. Das kann innerhalb von einer Viertelstunde aktiviert werden. Wir haben es gleich mit der DLR. Die Weilheim-Station in der Deutschen ist für unsere Missionen integral konfiguriert. Falls wir hier einen Ausfall oder einen Konflikt hatten, dass zu viele auf eine Station zugreifen wollen, können wir über das vordefinierte Verfahren mit der DLR innerhalb von einer Stunde, glaube ich, in ihren Anlage, wenn sie dann frei ist, benutzen.
Wie viele solchen Bodenstations-Netzwerke gibt es denn überhaupt? So weltweit?
So viele wie Raumfahrtbehörden plus ein paar, die nichts anderes betreiben. Also in Europa sind die größten natürlich. Das ESTRACK ist das größte in Europa. Die Franzosen haben ein sehr ausentwickeltes. Die DLR hat ein sehr kleines. Das ist primär die Weilheim-Station. Und Anteile an Stationen inzwischen in Kanada und Partneranlagen.
Also Netzwerk heißt in dem Fall vielleicht mehr als eine Bodenstation, aber jetzt nicht so eine globale Coverage, wie es die ESA hat?
Eine globale in Europa, nur die ESA und die CNES eigentlich.
Das heißt, die CNES hat auch nochmal mehrere Bodenstationen, die auch weltweit verteilt sind?
Ja, die hat ein komplettes Netz. Das ist primär deren erdnahe Missionen bedient. Das heißt, die haben keine Deep Space-Komponente, aber die haben Anlagen für ihre in der Regel erdnahen Erdbeobachtungsmission. Die NASA hat eben das größte Netz, dann die Russen, die Chinesen. Dann gibt es halt verschiedene kleinere Nationen. Die Inder zum Beispiel, die haben auch fast ein globales Netzwerk. Und dann gibt es halt kleinere Nationen, Italiener. Die haben eigentlich ein paar Stationen in Italien und in Kenia zum Beispiel. Die Südafrikaner haben eine eigene Station, wo sie auch viele andere Agenturen als Gäste haben. Dann gibt es zwei semi-kommerzielle Anbieter in Europa. Das sind zwei staatlich kontrollierte Firmen, jeweils in Norwegen und in Schweden. Die machen das kommerziell als Hauptgeschäft. Die haben aufgrund ihrer nordischen Lage Anlagen für Polarmissionen gebaut, die sie vermieten an die diversesten Kunden, die NASA, militärische Kunden, die ESA. Wir haben es vorhin schon erwähnt. Die machen ein Geschäft draus. Das ist ein selbst tragendes Geschäft. Inzwischen, aufgrund dieser großen Population an Erdbeobachtungsmissionen, können sie damit ein Geschäft betreiben. Die Norweger sind die Größeren. Die haben diese Anlage in Spitzbergen, die extrem nördlich ist und damit von daher nicht in Europa die beste Abdeckung bietet, weil jede polare Mission verfliegt einmal pro Revolution. Es gibt eine zweite Anlage in Antarktika, der Norweger, die das ergänzt. Trollen heißt die. Mit diesen beiden Anlagen sind sie eigentlich konkurrenzlos, was die Abdeckung anbelangt. Die Schweden haben ein ähnliches Konzept. Die haben ihre Anlage auch in Kiruna. Nicht weit weg von der ESA-Anlage. Die haben einen riesen Antennenfeld für ihre nationalen Programme. Die haben jetzt seit kurzem das ergänzende Anlage in Kanada. Die ist vom Längengrad her so konzipiert, dass die Kombination aus Kiruna und dieser kanadischen Station eine Abdeckung gewährleistet, die ähnlich ihrem Konkurrenten in Spitzbergen ist. Die beiden, die Norweger und die Schweden, sind aktive Konkurrenten in diesem Geschäft und überleben das Ganze mit einem kommerziellen Element. Auch wir bei der ESA haben mit diesen Partnern, mit diesen Providern Verträge und kaufen da eben dann konkurrieren Dienste ein, die wir nicht erbringen wollen oder können.
Und kann dann das ESTRACK da genauso drauf zugreifen wie auf die eigenen Bodenstationen?
Ja, wir haben das so eingerichtet. Aufgrund dieser besprochenen Standardisierung, die auf den kommerziellen Provider implementieren, können die Saliten selber auch wie ein Bodensegment von Boden zu Boden relativ problemlos diese Dienste in Anspruch nehmen. Das ist also das Schöne an diesen Standards, dass die inzwischen so weit verpreist sind, dass man eben problemlos wie beim Mobilfunk von Land zu Land, von Station zu Station wechseln kann, ohne großen Aufwand. Wenn man vorher bezahlt hat, einen Vertrag und ein Roman Agreement.
Ich finde das erstaunlich. Ich meine, auf der einen Seite ist es naheliegend, dass man das haben will. Auf der anderen Seite, finde ich, zeigt das auch sehr schön, wie eigentlich so diese ganze internationale Raumfahrtszene sich da eben auch, sagen wir mal, hin zu einer Kooperation und weg von so einem unmittelbaren, ausschließenden Wettbewerb zu einer internationalen Kooperationsphäre immer wieder zusammenschließt.
Ja gut, die Raumfahrt war immer schon extrem kooperationsorientiert. Die Europäer hatten in der Vergangenheit den Zwang zur Kooperation. Also man inno-europäisch. Es gibt keine großen Projekte, die national gemacht werden können in Europa aufgrund der finanziellen Kraft, die man dazu braucht. Und auch als Junior-Partner früher der Amerikaner. Und jetzt mit anderen Partnern. Europäer sind eigentlich genetisch im Raumfahrtgeschäft immer auf Kooperation angewiesen gewesen und können das auch ganz gut, glaube ich. Und wir hier in ESA, in diesem Kontrollzentrum, sind da vielleicht ein extremes Beispiel, weil dieses Bodennetzgeschäft ist weltweit extrem vernetzt. Also wir haben mit allen großen und kleinen Betreibern Verträge, Agreements, um uns auszutauschen. Es gibt sehr viel Cross-Support, eben, das die anderen Anlagen benutzt. Das ist für uns eigentlich ein ganz elementarer Bestandteil der Arbeit. Das sind rein nationale Missionen, die man unabhängig betreiben will von Partnern, die es die Militärs vielleicht brauchen und wollen, sind bei uns eher unbekannt. Wir haben überall, wir haben in den meisten Missionen, ein sehr starkes Kooperationselement, sei es mit nationalen Partnern oder mit internationalen.
Aber trotzdem ist ja das Misstrauen auch nicht vollständig von der Welt. Das Verhältnis zu China, denke ich, ist auch etwas, was sich das langsam klärt mit ihren Missionen. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, vom ESTRACK werden auch Dienstleistungen für andere Länder, die ihre eigenen Bodenstationsnetzwerke haben, auch durchgeführt, oder? Zum Beispiel auch mit China?
Wir hatten für die Chinesen einen Support für deren Mondmission, die Chang'e-Mission. Das ist eine Monderkundungsmission, als Vorbereitung für eine Landung, die den nächsten Jahren stattfinden wird. Erst um dem Land, dann beim Land. Und da hatten sie uns für den Transfer zum Mond Dienste angefragt. Das heißt, die hatten für diese Phase keine geeignete Bodenstation verfügbar. Deswegen haben wir unsere Anlage dafür genutzt und den Chinesen vermietet. Die Dienste verkauft. Das ist also auch ein neuerer Partner. Die Chinesen sind noch nicht so lange mit uns im Partnerschaftsgeschäft, aber seit einigen Jahren ist dem so. Die klassischen Partners sind natürlich die Amerikaner oder die anderen europäischen Raumfahrtbehörden. Wir haben mit der CNES sehr viel Austausch. Die CNES hat eben ihre Netzwerke weltweit, aber nicht in Lokationen, die für den Launch wichtig sind. Unsere Anlage in Australien, in Perth, ist die am häufigsten vermietete Bodenstation für Partner.
Warum?
Weil die für Arianestaats recht gut gelegen ist. Sei es ein GTO oder klassische Staat für eine geostationäre Mission oder auch für Polar-Missionen, ist das oft in dem Bereich, wo die Trennung von Satellit und Rakete gesehen wird. Deswegen können wir die relativ leicht verkaufen. Die ist extrem nachgefragt von Zwerg-Party-Leuten.
Das heißt, jetzt, wo sie gerade im Verdrängungswettbewerb mit der Stadt ist, ist der Neubau ein wichtiges Thema. Wird die dann ihren Ort wechseln müssen?
Man muss es abstrakter sehen. Die Station selber hat verschiedene Funktionen. Das eine ist im S-Band, das ist der kritische Faktor. Support zu den Missionen, die fliegen. Dieser S-Band-Support ist inzwischen etwas geworden, was man kommerziell einkaufen kann. Es gibt auch in Australien Firmen, die Schweden haben dort eine Filiale gegründet, von denen man solche Dienste einkaufen kann. Das heißt, wir könnten auch überlegen, ob wir das kommerziell einkaufen. Daneben hat die Station auch einen zweiten Zweck. Das ist das Tracking von Raketen, von Launchers im S-Band. Das ist auch von diesem Frequenzlizenzproblem betroffen. Der dritte Zweck der Station ist Support im X-Band. Dieser Support ist von diesem Frequenzlizenz nicht betroffen. Wir haben diese drei Funktionen, S-Band, TTNC, X-Band, TTC und Launcher Tracking. Nur die beiden S-Band-Funktionen sind von dieser Problematik betroffen. Wir überlegen uns, ob wir die Station umziehen. Das wäre eine Variante. Ob wir eine neue bauen oder ob wir das zum Teil oder ganz einkaufen. Das ist nur unter einer internen Diskussion. Aber diese Verzahnung von kommerziellen Diensten und Selbstverbrachung in ESTRACK ist bei uns ein wichtiges Thema für die Neuausrichtung der ESTRACK Evolution.
Wenn jetzt so viel getragen ist von Automatisierung, langfristiger Planung, eigentlich läuft immer alles und die Kängurus lassen einen eigentlich auch in Ruhe. Was sind denn dann so die herausragenden Momente beim Betrieb einer solchen Bodenstation? Gibt es so Dinge, die jetzt so sehr aus der Reihe fallen, dass sie so mit dem normalen Betrieb nicht zu vergleichen sind? Gibt es Momente, wo auch die spezifische Herausforderung jetzt einfach deutlich höher ist? Als das normalerweise der Fall ist? Also sich heißt, Mondmission beobachten, dass Dinge auf einmal ganz anders laufen müssen und dass es auch einen Entwicklungsbedarf vielleicht gibt, wo man sich auch mal Gedanken drüber machen muss, ok, alles klar, wir können irgendwie das, das, das und das. Aber hier gibt es jetzt irgendwie eine spezielle Anforderung, die wir jetzt so mit unserem Netzwerk gar nicht leisten können. Wie kriegen wir das hin?
Also es gibt vielleicht zwei große Herausforderungen. Das eine ist im Vorfeld, das haben sie eben angesprochen, eine Neukonstruktion, Umbau, Erweiterung der Anlagen, weil sie die neuen Bedürfnisse nicht erfüllen können. Das ist ein Engineering-Prozess, der geht über Jahre. Das ist in der Regel ein sehr kreatives Element, wo man eben die Umwandlung von Bedürfnissen, von Missionen, in Betriebsanforderungen, in technische Spezifikation, in den Bau von Anlagen verfolgen kann. Das ist eine Arbeit, die sehr viele, gerade jüngere Ingenieure, sehr stark motiviert und begeistert. Ich würde sagen, der kreative Prozess, die Teilnahme an diesem kreativen Prozess über mehrere Jahre. Der andere, vielleicht aber emotional noch gewichtigere Höhepunkt der Arbeit hier, ist in der Regel die Teilnahme an Staats. Weil beim Start einer Mission haben sie in allen Rollen, die es da gibt im Zentrum, eine sehr starke emotionale Bindung zum Erfolg oder Misserfolg dieser Mission. In der Regel ist er der Stationsbetreiber. Das wird in der Regel von einer Person ausgeführt, die dann eine Funktion hat als Operations Manager für ESTRACK. Das ist dann eine Rolle, bei der ein erfahrener Operations Engineer in der Regel dann die Betriebsführung des ESTRACK-Netzwerkes dann direkt überwacht und steuert. In dieser Rolle ist man sehr nahe an diesem kritischen Moment, wenn die Satellite hochgesetzt wird von der Rakete und dann sein Sender hoffentlich angeht und dann hoffentlich ein Signal erzeugt, das man deuten kann mit Telemetrie, und man auch diese Mission dann sieht. Das heißt, das Einfangen des ersten Signals ist meistens ein emotionaler absoluter Höhepunkt, der dann auch mit dem RITUS normalerweise beendet wird. We have a mission. Und ohne dieses magische Statement, das mir dann minder streng verfolgt wird, gibt es eigentlich keine Mission. Das ist dann der Moment, wo Leute auch dann zum Teil in Tränen ausbrechen. Weil eben der Moment ist, wo dann eine jahrelange Arbeit sich dann zeigt in einem Erfolg, in einem in dem Fall messbaren Telemetrie-Signal, dessen Hoffentlichkeit zeigt, dass das Ateliet auch gesund ist und seine Mission fortsetzen kann. Ich habe schon Leute wirklich weinen sehen, gestandene, taffe Ingenieure, die in diesem Augenblick dann so bewegt sind von ihrem Ergebnis, dass sie dann in Tränen ausbrechen. Das ist schon sehr bewegend.
Es ist ja hier auch schon in einigen Gesprächen häufiger zur Sprache gekommen, auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise. Ausgabe 4 zum Beispiel, Operations, wurde ja viel über die Steuerung konkret von Missionen gesprochen, was ja im Prinzip in dem Moment erst beginnt. Es ist ja nicht nur so, dass die Arbeit der zurückliegenden Jahre in dem Moment im Fokus ist, sondern dass viel Arbeit überhaupt erst beginnen kann, dadurch dass diese Mission startet. Nicht nur bei den Wissenschaftlern, sondern auch bei den Leuten, die diese Mission dann später führen. Inwieweit ist denn dann das ESTRACK-Team wirklich real eingebunden in solche Starts? Wir hatten ja vorhin schon diese Testphase. Man muss halt vorher sicherstellen, dass das Ding eben auch die richtige Sprache spricht. Aber ab welchem Moment ist man denn in so eine Startphase dann auch unmittelbar eingebunden?
Also während der Startphase gibt es hier eine riesen Mannschaft, wie in allen Kontrollzentren, die für diese Startphase nur eingerichtet wird. Eine temporäre Projektstruktur, geleitet vom Flight Operations Director, der wichtigsten Mann dann über diese Wochen und Monate. Und in diesem Team gibt es dann eine Rolle, die ist dieser erwähnte Ground Operations Manager, der dann für das gesamte Bodensegment ist. Das ist Bodensstation, aber auch Kommunikationseinrichtungen und andere Elemente des Bodensegments verantwortlich ist.
Das heißt, Bodensegment ist jetzt nicht identisch zu ESTRACK, sondern ESTRACK ist nur ein Teil.
Der größte Teil davon.
Der größte, ja. Und was kommt da noch dazu?
Die Bodenkommunikation, dieses IP-Netzwerk zum Teil. Das ist auch zum Teil das Kontrollzentrum an sich. Die Infrastruktur des Kontrollzentrums. Nicht die Kantine. Die Kantine unterstützt direkt den Dem-Director. Das heißt aber, dieser Operations Manager, der Ground Operations Manager, ist dann zuständig für die Vorbereitung dieser Elemente für den Start. Und das ist eine Rolle, die wird in der Regel aktiviert zwei Monate vor dem Start. Und das ist dann die eigentliche Operationsvorbereitung. Während dieser Phase werden dann viele Simulationen gefahren, um das Team einzuspielen. Das Team, das den Spacecraft betreibt, auch das Team, das die Stationen betreibt. Also sie müssen sich einspielen, sie müssen die Prozeduren kennenlernen, sie müssen ihre Rolle finden. Und es ist dann, ja, es ist zugleich eine Team-Building, aber auch eine Validierungssimulationsphase über zwei Monate. Und in dieser Phase findet sich das Team. Und auch die Schwächen und Stärken der einzelnen Figuren in diesem Team.
Kennen die sich nicht schon sowieso alle schon?
Die meisten kennen sich, aber nicht immer an den Rollen, die sie dann da einnehmen.
Das heißt dann, okay, verstehe, da wird dann etwas anderes aktiviert, als das normalerweise der Fall ist.
Da kommen dann die Charaktere richtig zum Vorschein, die guten und manchmal schwierigen Elemente. Wichtig ist auch, die ESTRACK-Leute, die haben relativ viele von diesen Starterlebnissen. Nächstes Jahr zum Beispiel haben wir hier zwölf Startunterstützung, das ist extrem viel, zwölf pro Jahr, während nur vier Spacecraft von hier gesteuert werden in den Start. Das heißt, die Missionsleute, die haben ihre Mission, die bereiten vor, fliegen die, machen das dann ein, zwei Mal im Leben, während eben die ESTRACK als Support-Einrichtung Start sehr viel häufiger erlebt. Aber die Abstimmung zwischen diesen Mission-Teams, die das relativ selten machen, und diesen, z.B. die routinierteren, aber eben aus anderer Ecke kommenden ESTRACK-Leuten, sind immer auch ein Abstimmungsprozess, der durch Teambuilding auch erst erfolgen muss. Da müssen die Charaktere passen, die müssen die Arbeitsweisen, die Regeln kennen, die Prozeduren, die Eigenschaften der Mission. Das geht dann über diesen Zeitraum von ungefähr zwei Monaten. Dann während der eigenen Startphase natürlich, sind die ESTRACK-Mannschaften dann vor Ort und hier in der ESOC, im Betrieb rund um die Uhr wie alle anderen Mannschaften auch. Das geht dann je nach Charakteristika des Orbits, typischerweise drei Tage bis eine Woche, wenn alles gut geht.
Zwei Monate Vorbereitung für zwölf Missionen im Jahr, heißt ja, dass man auch an zweien gleichzeitig arbeitet. Sind das dann separate Teams oder muss man sich dann auch wirklich auf mehrere Starts parallel einstellen?
Nein, die Teams sind nicht überlappend, das wäre nicht handhabbar. Das ist eine getrennte Mannschaft. Das heißt, wir müssen genügend Personal eingestellt haben, um diese Überlappung dann handhaben zu können. Die Kernmannschaften, das heißt, die Ingenieur-Teams pro Start sind sechs bis acht Leute plus die Leute, die vor Ort sind, in den Stationen jeweils im ESTRACK-Bereich. Das heißt, bei zwölf Starts haben wir zwölfmal diese Gruppengröße, schon eine hohe Anforderung an die Personalstärke, die wir da bereitstellen müssen. Manche Leute machen das ganz begeistert. Die sind sozusagen addicted, abhängig von diesem Adrenalinstoß. Deswegen sind die hier und arbeiten hier. Die brauchen das, die wollen diesen Rausch haben, die Herausforderung, dieses Erlebnis, das ich an diesem großen Projekt mitgearbeitet habe. Ich habe da das erste Kommando geschickt oder die Telemetrie empfangen. Die sind davon echt elektrisiert. Wir haben da mehrere davon. Die meisten sehen es natürlich eher als Belastung. Es sind Nachtschichten, die Familie leidet, es ist anstrengend. Es ist manchmal auch eine eintönige Arbeit in Phasen. Es gibt auch diese Teambildungsprozesse, die manchmal ein bisschen anstrengend sein können. Aber in der Regel ist das, was die Leute mit nach Hause nehmen. Das ist das Wichtigste, was wir an der ESOC bieten können, ein Erlebnis, die Teilhabe an so einem Start, an so einem großen Erlebnis. Das ist eben doch ein Effort von vielen, vielen Leuten in Europa, die dann hier zusammenkommen, um diesen einen Moment zu erleben, um das Ding da von der Erde weg in den Weltraum zu schießen und hoffentlich dann gute Wissenschaft damit betreiben zu können.
Ich glaube, jeder, der mal an so einem Projekt gearbeitet hat, wo klar ist, das findet nur zu einem einzigen Zeitpunkt statt oder es findet nicht statt, egal, ob das welche Veranstaltungen sind oder technische Planungen, kennt so ein bisschen diesen Effekt, was sich da alles löst. Trotz alledem, wenn Leute das so unterschiedlich aufnehmen, manche da mit Euphorie, manchmal vielleicht auch zu viel Euphorie, dabei sind und es natürlich auch eine psychische Belastung darstellt, trotz, sagen wir mal, erlösendem Moment, dass man da auch einfach drunter leidet, wie wichtig ist denn die psychologische Komponente und inwieweit ist die dann auch Teil der Teamführung?
Also die Teamfähigkeit unserer Mitarbeiter ist essentiell. Wir prüfen das über verschiedene Methoden, also schon bei der Einstellung darauf geachtet, dass die Leute, die zu uns kommen, den einen vermitteln, dass sie im Team arbeiten können und auch Teams leiten können für ESA Staff. Und das wird eben abgeprüft durch verschiedene Techniken, Methoden, im Interview. Man sieht es ja auch dann in der Einarbeitungsphase in ihren ersten Team einsetzen, wie weit die Leute fähig und willig sind, als Team zu arbeiten. Wir hatten auch schon Phasen, wo bestimmte Teams eine Betreuung brauchten über einen externen Teambilder, über einen Psychologen, über einen Mentor, über einen Coach, der Leuten hilft, zusammen zu finden. Wir hatten auch schon Leute, um auf ihren Stressfaktor zu kommen, die diesen Anforderungen nicht gewachsen waren, die einfach an psychisch diesem selbstgemachten oder auch von außen herangetragenen Druck im Team an diesen komplexen Arbeiten zu arbeiten nicht gewachsen waren. Aber die meisten, die hier kommen, die wollen das, die wissen das und sind dann nicht ganz erfolgreich damit, diese Belastung zu verarbeiten. Wir haben noch hier ein sehr starkes Familiengefühl. Diese ESOC-Family ist ein sehr starkes Element, immer sichtbar auch in privaten Veranstaltungen, in Firmenveranstaltungen. Wer lange hier arbeitet, und das tun die meisten, wir haben eine extrem geringe Fluktuation, wird irgendwann Teil dieser ESOC-Family. Und auch diese Bindung ist sehr entscheidend, weil viele wollen eine gute Arbeit machen, aber sie wollen auf keinen Fall ihren Kollegen reinreiten oder der sein, der dieses Gesamtprojekt eben vermasselt. Das heißt, dieses kameradschaftliche, dieses Gruppendenken ist sehr stark vorhanden. Und es ist ein Motivationsfakt, den wir auch pflegen, weil es die Leute motiviert, weil es auch ein sehr, finde ich, für mich persönlich angenehmes Teil von der ESOC ist.
Und das zählt dann auch die Schwächeren mit, also die zumindest in manchen Phasen vielleicht nicht unbedingt immer das Maß haben. Ich meine, es mag ja auch einfach Einflüsse geben, die jetzt überhaupt nicht unter der Kontrolle irgendeines Computers oder Teams stehen. Einfach persönliche private Momente, wo man eben nicht immer die volle Leistungsfähigkeit abrufen kann. Auch etwas, was mir jetzt von meinen wenigen Besuchen hier beim ESOC schon aufgefallen ist, dass das doch hier ein sehr vertrauter Umgang miteinander hier vorherrscht. Was für Leute finden denn den Weg in so ein ESTRACK-Team? Was für Menschen werden denn gesucht? Also jetzt unabhängig von den Teamfähigkeiten und Voraussetzungen, die man jetzt so dem Einzelnen noch gerne nahelegt. Sind das alles Ingenieure? Gibt es da bestimmt Ausbildungen, die hier besonders vorherrschen? Oder ist das bunt gemischt?
Natürlich stellen wir Leute an mit akademischer Ausbildung. Das ist schon eine Voraussetzung für die meisten Jobs im Operationsbereich. In der Regel sind das Naturwissenschaftler, Ingenieure. Wir haben aber auch ein paar Exoten bei uns. Wir haben Biologen eingestellt, Astrophysiker, Historiker auch schon mal. Leute, die einfach starkes Interesse haben für die Arbeit hier und geschickt im Umgang mit Menschen, mit Strukturen, die sich in diese betrieblichen Probleme eindenken können.
Also ist nicht ausgewählt worden, weil er Historiker, sondern obwohl er Historiker ist.
Natürlich sind es vom Job ab. Sie können nicht einen Historiker auf eine Entwicklungsaufgabe im Softwarebereich setzen, normalerweise. Aber ich habe in meinem Team einen Biologen, der ist sehr managementorientiert, sehr prozessorientiert. Der kam schon im Studium hier als Praktikant sozusagen. Und der funktioniert hervorragend. Er ist ein sehr starker Mitarbeiter und hat jetzt gar keine technische Ausbildung. Wir hatten auch schon Astrophysiker hier, die sonst keinen Job finden. Die kommen als Verwandter. Das ist jetzt eine Operations von Wissenschaftsmissionen. Aber in der Regel sind das wie gesagt eben Akademiker mit gutem Abschluss. Eine nationale Komponente müssen sie haben in irgendeiner Form. Sei es für Deutsche ein Auslandsaufenthalt und ein Auslandsstudium. Oder für Nichtdeutsche eben auch idealerweise ein Aufenthalt außerhalb des Landes, bevor sie zur ESO kommen. Sehr viele kommen halt schon aus der Rampartindustrie. Wir haben die Gerätschaften herstellen, die Satelliten, die Bodensegmentinstallationen. Oder aus dem Service-Bereich.
Gibt es denn jetzt akademische Ausbildungen, die jetzt besonders viel vertreten sind? Ich weiß nicht, sind das dann Mathematiker?
Also in unserem Bereich, ESTRACK sind das primär Naturwissenschaftliche. Also Physiker, Ingenieure in der Regel, Elektro- und Telekommunikation, Informatiker. Das sind so die Hauptgruppe.
Ja, haben wir denn noch etwas Wichtiges vergessen? Zum Thema Bodenstationen, ESTRACK im Besonderen, Steuerung der Missionen. Ich habe den Eindruck, wir haben jetzt alles ganz gut durchmarschiert hier.
Wir haben einige interessante Aspekte gestreift. Und aus meiner Sicht die wichtigsten Themen...
Was war denn das persönliche Highlight dieser ganzen Zeit?
Für mich persönlich? Ich würde sagen, das sind immer wieder mehrfach schon diese Starterlebnisse. Das ist auch für mich etwas, was mich immer wieder kitzelt, was einen Stress beursacht, eine Aufregung. Und wenn es dann erfolgreich ist, immer auch so ein Stolz, so ein Kitzel dabei gewesen zu sein, dann wird es auch einen kleinen Beitrag geleistet zu haben. Dieses Starterlebnis ist, glaube ich, die größte Droge, die man von hier mitnehmen kann. Das gilt für die meisten Menschen, für mich auch.
Ist das dann egal, was startet? Oder gab es dann noch mal Starts, die irgendwie anders waren?
Ja gut, das kann jetzt schlecht unterscheiden. Ich würde sagen, natürlich sind die Starts am bewegendesten, wo man lange dabei war. Ich habe früher für die Mission XMM, das ist eine Röntgen-Mission, das Bodensegment vorbereitet, als Projektleiter, und dann war dann beim Start auch in Kourou anwesend. Das hat mich natürlich sehr stark bewegt, weil ich da Jahre meines Berufslebens investiert habe. Jetzt, wenn ich in der letzten Phase dazu komme, ist es nicht ganz so lebensumfassend. Aber ich kann das immer noch teilen, diese Begeisterung, dieser Kitzel. Ein anderer Aspekt, der für mich auch sehr stimulierend ist hier, ist diese Mischung an Menschen. Wir haben diese Nationalitäten aus ganz Europa, aber auch weltweit. Wir haben in Argentinien bei uns Amerikaner, Russen, Asiaten, die hier arbeiten. Wir arbeiten mit den Agencies, wirklich weltweit zusammen. Man kann auch diese Anlagen besuchen, diese Länder von innen kennenlernen, auch die Leute in der Arbeitsumgebung kennenlernen. Das ist sicherlich etwas, was mich ganz stark bewegt. Und dann auch in meiner Management-Rolle die Herausforderungen in einem recht komplexen Umfeld, die Prozesse halt steuern. Das ist eine nicht technische Herausforderung, die in der Raumfahrt ganz groß ist, weil wir da sehr viele komplexe Projekte haben. Schiffsbau vielleicht auch, ich weiß nicht, oder große Baukomplexe. Aber die Raumfahrt ist halt ein klassischer Bereich für extrem komplexe Projekte und Abwicklungen. Und diese Möglichkeit, hier zu haben, auszuleben, ist für mich auch sehr stimulierend.
Ja, ein schöner Abschluss, die Komplexität der Raumfahrt zu diskutieren. Das ist ja hier die Aufgabe von Raumzeiten. Und ich denke, dann machen wir jetzt hier mal einen Punkt. Vielen Dank, Thomas Beck. Und vielen Dank auch wieder mal allen Hörern hier beim Zuhören unserer Reise durchs All. Und das war die Ausgabe von Raumzeit zu dem Bodenstationnetzwerk ESTRACK. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald bei Raumzeit.